et bonne année 2023 à chacun d'entre
vous et à vos familles et vos proches
[Applaudissements]
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement et la première question va
être posée par Monsieur Christophe neige
laine merci madame la Présidente pour
cette toute première question au
gouvernement de l'année je tenais à
souhaiter à tous mes meilleurs vœux pour
cette année 2023 mais je les s'adresse
surtout à nos concitoyens des vœux de
santé mais aussi d'espoir et de courage
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie
j'aurais pu vous parler de cette usine
textile du Thillot qui a vu ses factures
d'électricité annuelle passée de 1
million à 2 millions d'euros et qui se
retrouvent encore plus en difficulté
face à la concurrence internationale
j'aurais pu aussi vous parler de ce
boulanger de la Bresse qui lui a vu sa
facture mensuelle passée du simple au
double l'obligeant ainsi à augmenter sa
baguette de 30% impactant ainsi le
quotidien
pour qu'on puisse écouter la première
question de l'année merci merci madame
la Présidente j'aurais pu enfin vous
parler de ce restaurateur Omari Montain
qui va devoir s'inquiéter d'une facture
de 90000 euros alors qu'elle était de
9600 euros l'an passé et qui prie à la
gorge hésite à poursuivre son activité
mais en réalité cette situation loin
d'être unique au territoire vosgien
impacte tous les Français avec des
conséquences à minima compliqué et
parfois catastrophique
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie nous
n'allons pas ici débattre de nouveau de
ces causes car ce qui intéresse avant
tout nos concitoyens c'est le futur
c'est demain et comment résoudre ces
problèmes au plus vite j'ai donc deux
questions très simples l'une à l'échelle
de l'Union européenne lorsque la France
était à la présence du Conseil le
président de la République avait évoqué
une refonte du marché européen de
l'électricité que comptez-vous faire
aujourd'hui et prévoyez-vous de sortir
de ce marché enfin au niveau national de
nombreuses entreprises principalement
nos PME ne sont pas concernés par les
aides ou quand elles le sont rencontre
des difficultés importantes pour y avoir
droit que comptez-vous faire pour ne
laisser personne au bord de la route
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire ministre de l'Économie
des Finances de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique
vœux pour cette première question à
l'ensemble de la représentation
parlementaire et puisque vous m'y
invitez monsieur député je voudrais vous
présenter les mesures d'aide que nous
avons mises en place avec la première
ministre avec le président de la
République pour toutes les entreprises
françaises qui font que les très petites
entreprises dont vous m'avez parlé sont
aujourd'hui les mieux protégés de toutes
les petites entreprises de l'Union
européenne il y a deux virgule un
million de très petites entreprises
1,5 millions d'entre elles ont droit au
tarif régulés sont protégés par le
bouclier tarifaire aucun autre pays
européen d'amis de bouquet tarifaire en
place pour les très petits entreprises
5,5 millions il en restait 600 000 elles
ont lancé un cri d'appel à LED nous les
avons entendu en leur garantissant après
une longue négociation avec les
fournisseurs d'énergie un tarif moyen de
l'électricité à 2 le mégawattheure en
moyenne sur l'année 2023 c'est une
protection massive que nous leur
apportons très loin des 500 600 000
euros le mégawattheure qu'ils avaient dû
payer tous les boulangers de France tous
les artisans tous les très petits
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés tous
les bouchers toutes les professions qui
aujourd'hui étaient inquiète peuvent
être rassurés leurs factures ne
dépassera pas 280 euros en moyenne sur
l'année 2023 et celle qui aurait encore
des difficultés on doit un amortisseur
qui réduit la facture de 20% et celle
qui aurait encore des difficultés au
droit également un guichet qui peut
réduire l'augmentation de la facture
jusqu'à 40%, je le confirme les très
petites entreprises françaises sont
protégées comme aucune autre et petits
entreprises dans l'Union européenne
reste des PME nous allons y continuer à
y travailler avec Olivia Grégoire et sur
le marché au pan de l'énergie vous
attendrez la question suivante pour que
je vous apporte une réponse précise
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Laurence vichnowski
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente je pense que
ma question s'adresse à la fois à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie et à
Madame Agnès panier rue naché sur ce
thème effectivement de l'augmentation du
prix de l'électricité le 1er février
prochain la hausse des factures
d'électricité des Français sera de 15%
cette hausse déjà considérable et
pourtant contenue par le bouclier
tarifaire mis en place par le
gouvernement les Français ne comprennent
pas cette explosion des prix alors même
que nous disposons de ressources
énergétiques stables et pérenne
largement grâce à nos centrales
nucléaires le système est opaque et son
fonctionnement illisible nombre
d'artisans et de commerçants risquent de
ne pas passer l'hiver les alertes
quotidiennes de nos boulangers en
témoignent si nous devons accompagner
nos entreprises et les ménages dans les
médias ce soutien ne peut être que
temporaire nos finances publiques
pour contenir ces explosions de prix
c'est bien le fonctionnement structurel
du marché européen de l'énergie qui doit
être repensée le prix de notre
électricité ne peut plus dépendre de
celui du gaz monsieur le ministre madame
la ministre
pouvez-vous pouvez-vous expliquer au
français pourquoi la France ne peut pas
sortir du système européen qui paraît
ainsi nous pénalisé et je pense et je
pense aux dérogation qui ont été
accordées à l'Espagne et au Portugal
nous savons que des discussions sont
engagées avec nos voisins pour rendre le
prix de l'énergie plus juste et plus
conforme aux ressources de chacun ou en
sommes-nous quand peut-on espérer
aboutir les Français nous attendent avec
raison sur ce sujet déterminant pour
notre économie et notre climat social je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
ministre de la transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés d'abord tous mes
vœux pour cette nouvelle année et puis
madame la députée ski merci de rappeler
d'abord tous les efforts faits par le
gouvernement et qui ont encore été à
l'instant mis en avant par Monsieur le
Ministre de l'économie pour protéger les
Français contre l'augmentation de prix
l'électricité et l'augmentation du prix
du gaz nous sommes le pays qui
protégeons le plus nos ménages et nos
entreprises contre l'augmentation de
cette prix merci également de me donner
l'occasion de dire que ce bouclier il
est en partie financé par une mesure qui
a été pris au niveau européen mesure qui
permet justement de prendre la rente que
génère c'est au prix de gaz et
l'électricité et de faire en sorte de la
redistribuer au consommateurs et je
crois que c'est très exactement le sens
de notre action c'est de faire en sorte
que de manière équilibrée les
consommateurs puissent bénéficier de ces
cet effet d'augmentation des prix et que
cela leur revienne et cela permet de les
protéger aujourd'hui enfin vous
m'interrogez sur la réforme du marché
d'électricité d'abord sachez
qu'effectivement cela fait deux ans que
nous avons
entamé des discussions pour découpler le
marché du gaz du marché d'électricité
mais je veux rappeler une chose si nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans le marché
européen et si nous passons l'hiver dans
de bonnes conditions c'est parce que
nous bénéficions des exportations
d'électricité de l'Espagne de
l'Allemagne lorsque notre propre système
électrique est en tension et si les prix
l'électricité ont augmenté ce n'est pas
seulement la faute des prix du gaz c'est
aussi le fait qu'aujourd'hui mais nous y
travaillons notre système électrique est
sous tension pour des raisons de
maintenance de nos centrales nucléaires
alors l'action du gouvernement elle est
très claire
une action déterminée pour la réforme du
marché d'électricité en Europe mais
également une action déterminée pour
renforcer notre système électrique et
vous aurez l'occasion de faire en votant
le projet de loi
merci la parole est à monsieur le
Président marlex pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
la droite française a toujours assumé de
Jacques Chirac à Nicolas Sarkozy de
réformer les retraites pour sauvegarder
notre système par répartition la
répartition c'est un principe de
solidarité dans lequel c'est le travail
des Français qui finance les retraites
c'est le contraire du chacun pour soi
c'est le système le plus protecteur pour
les Français les plus modestes
aujourd'hui ce système est menacé là où
il y avait quatre actifs pour un
retraité dans les années 70 il n'y en a
plus qu'un,7 les déficits annoncés
auront une conséquence et une seule la
baisse du niveau des pensions pour les
retraités et nous le refusons
la réforme que nous voulons elle tient
en quelques principes d'abord elle doit
être progressive le recul de l'âge ne
doit intervenir qu'au rythme d'un
trimestre par an jusqu'à 63 ans à la fin
de ce quinquennat 64 ans dans le suivant
ensuite elle doit être juste et
permettre à celui qui a commencé plus
tôt de partir à la retraite plutôt dès
lors qu'il a tout ce trimestre elle doit
aussi être équitable en demandant le
même effort à tous les Français public
privé régime spéciaux enfin soyons
clairs il est hors de question que
l'État s'empare des réserves du privé
l'argent des retraites doit aller au
retraité et à eux seuls
mais par dessus tout il faut réparer une
injustice c'est 2 millions de retraités
qui ont cotisé toute leur vie ont
travaillé dur en des carrières complètes
souvent des femmes des commerçants des
artisans qui perçoivent aujourd'hui des
retraites indignes autour de 900 euros
par mois c'est un digne d'un grand pays
comme le nôtre êtes-vous prête madame la
Première ministre à leur garantir à eux
aussi une retraite minimum de 1200 euros
et pas seulement au futur retraités je
vous le dis très clairement c'est pour
nous une condition impérative merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président marlex je voudrais profiter de
cette première question d'actualité pour
souhaiter mes meilleurs vœux à
l'ensemble des députés alors
collaborateurs et au service de
l'Assemblée nationale
alors monsieur le Président marlex vous
nous interrogez sur notre projet pour
les retraites vous le comprendrez les
quelques minutes qui me sont accordés
dans le cadre de ces questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement ne vont pas
me permettre de vous exposer la totalité
de ce projet
mais vous aurez l'occasion d'en débattre
très rapidement et je sais combien le
sujet des petites pensions vous tient à
cœur et importe à votre groupe nous en
avons parlé à de nombreuses reprises
lors de nos rencontres depuis octobre
pour préparer le projet de réforme des
retraites vous le savez j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire cette
préoccupation je la partage mon
gouvernement la partage dès la campagne
le président de la République avait pris
l'engagement de porter le montant de la
pension minimale à 85% du SMIC pour une
carrière complète soit bientôt 1200
euros par mois
dans quelques heures je serai donc amené
à présenter notre projet pour les
retraites mais je vous le confirme
monsieur le Président l'engagement du
président de la République sera tenu
c'est un progrès social
c'est un progrès social important
attendu et vous l'avez souligné qui sont
ces retraités ces personnes qui touchent
des petites pensions 60% sont des femmes
qui ont souvent eu des carrières
incomplètes des carrières hachées ce
sont aussi des indépendants des artisans
des commerçants qui ont passé une vie de
travail sans pouvoir se verser un
salaire suffisant alors monsieur le
Président de marlex nous avons également
échangé ces derniers jours sur la
situation des retraités qui après toute
une vie de travail avec un revenu
modeste touche aujourd'hui de très
petites pensions je vous confirme
monsieur le Président que j'ai bien
entendu la demande de votre groupe nous
partageons cette préoccupation une
carrière complète doit permettre d'avoir
une pension digne j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir tout à l'heure mais nous sommes
prêts à y travailler je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Madame Clémence guetter
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre après avoir juré de ne
pas toucher à l'âge de la retraite
monsieur Macron a un nouveau projet la
nécessité impérieuse urgente et cette
fois-ci la retraite à 64 ans pour
combler le léger déficit à venir surtout
pas de cotisations sur les dividendes ou
les traits au salaire surtout surtout il
vous faut continuer à empiler les
cadeaux fiscaux même si au passage vous
allez faire bondir les dépenses pour
financer RSA invalidité et chômage parce
qu'aujourd'hui à 62 ans celles et ceux
qui ne sont pas encore à la retraite
sont déjà 40% à ne plus travailler
demain ils seront plus nombreux encore à
être malade cassé par le travail plonger
dans la précarité au chômage de longue
durée instrument superflu de votre
nouveau monde grâce à la pluie de la
droite vous prévoyez d'enlever de la vie
aux années et des années à la vie c'est
en effet 15
personne de plus qui mourront chaque
année avant la retraite ce jour madame
la ministre disciple le flou sur vos
intentions pour un cariste qui a
commencé à travailler à 18 ans ce sera
deux ans de plus pour une aide-soignante
mère de deux enfants qui a commencé à 21
ans deux ans de plus aussi le coup près
que vous allez faire tomber va s'abattre
sur des corps sur des familles et sur
des vies et vous voulez pour cela passer
en force contre cet assemblée où vous
prévoyez déjà un 49-3 déguisé ou pas
contre les organisations de jeunesse qui
nous donne rendez-vous le 21 janvier
contre les syndicats qui se préparent à
une mobilisation historique contre enfin
et surtout les trois quarts des Français
qui expriment clairement leur volonté la
retraite à 60 ans du temps libéré pour
soi pour les siens pour les autres c'est
le sens du progrès social qui se combine
aujourd'hui à écologique vers la
réduction du temps de travail alors
madame la Première ministre renoncer je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Clémence guettait nous dites est-ce
qu'il y a urgence oui il y a urgence
madame il y a urgence parce que le
rapport du corps le corps composé des
partenaires sociaux montrent que dès
2027 ce sont 12,5 milliards d'euros de
déficit que dès 2030 c'est 15 milliards
d'euros qu'en 2035 c'est 20 milliards
d'euros qu'en 2040 c'est 25 milliards
d'euros de déficit et si vous considérez
qu'il n'y a pas urgence c'est parce que
vous acceptez le risque de casser le
système de retraite pour nos enfants de
leur léguer un système de protection
sociale au rabais assommé par la dette
étouffé par les impôts nous nous
considérons que l'équilibre est
nécessaire nous considérons que le
premier œil de protection le premier est
de solidarité c'est de sauver le système
par répartition et sur le deuxième point
que vous avez évoqué madame la députée
vous parlez des mesures que nous allons
annoncer tout à l'heure vous parlez sans
savoir vous parlez sans savoir et vous
vous pensez sans penser vous êtes le
seul groupe à n'avoir formulé aucune
proposition aucune alternative à ne pas
avoir participé au concertation et ne
pas voir jouer le jeu du dialogue
républicain nous allons mener cette
réforme pour les français pour nos
enfants pour nos petits-enfants et nous
n'allons pas sombrer dans la démagogique
et la vôtre la retraite à 60 ans c'est
85 milliards d'euros par an où est-ce
que vous les prenez
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur le questerworth
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente du travail aujourd'hui
c'est un jour important puisqu'à près un
dialogue intense le gouvernement va
présenter le contenu de la réforme des
retraites c'est une réforme
indispensable c'est une réforme au
service de l'intérêt général et au
service de notre modèle social alors que
son annoncé 25 années de déficit si on
ne fait rien il nous faut apporter des
réponses solides pour protéger le régime
par répartition qui est l'expression
d'une chaîne de solidarité
intergénérationnelle cette réforme elle
doit être efficace lorsqu'on parle de
retraite on parle d'âge chacun pense
immédiatement à l'âge et refusé comme
certains voudraient le faire de ne pas
de parler de l'âge ce serait éclipsé le
débat un peu comme si on parlait de
mariage sans parler d'amour
gouverner c'est affronté la réalité je
comprends bien que l'augmentation de
l'âge de départ fasse politiquement peur
mais la politique c'est d'abord du
courage cette réforme elle doit être
efficace mais elle doit être juste la
retraite est le reflet des choix
professionnels et familiaux de chacun au
sein du système de retraite il existe
une multitude de dispositifs qui
viennent adoucir les inégalités
accumulées tout au long de la carrière
professionnelle cependant ce n'est pas
au seul régime de retraite de résoudre
les injustices de la vie il faut les
résoudre avant si le rapport au travail
évolue en fonction de l'expérience et de
l'âge de chacun la notion de pénibilité
est centrale et seule la prévention
permettra réellement de la diminuer à la
racine et de réduire l'usure physique au
travail une referme une réforme des
travail des retraites c'est d'abord une
réforme de société augmenter l'âge de
départ c'est changer le regard de notre
société sur le travail à ce titre le
rôle de chaque entreprise et fondamental
le degré d'implication des entreprises
dans la durée conditionne le succès de
la réforme et les pouvoirs publics
devront accompagner les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent le faire ainsi
monsieur le ministre je n'ai aucun doute
que le dialogue avec les entreprises est
aujourd'hui fructueux je voudrais
simplement au travers de cette réponse
pouvoir avec vous le vérifier je vous
remercie monsieur lequestar la parole
est à Monsieur Olivier du stop ministre
du Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Quester verte votre question
me permet d'abord de répéter de
souligner l'importance qu'il y a amené
cette réforme pour établir l'équilibre
du régime de retraite j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire à maintes reprises améliorer
le déficit son équilibré n'est pas
responsable l'équilibre est sans
l'améliorer serait injuste et donc c'est
bien l'amélioration et l'équilibre que
nous recherchons nous le faisons dans le
lien le social via le social avec tous
les partenaires sociaux ils ont tous
participé au concertation que nous avons
mené au cours des dernières semaines
nous avons construit des convergences
nous avons aussi acté un certain de
désaccord et la transparence du dialogue
social de la démocratie sociale commande
aussi de dire lorsqu'il y a des accords
ou différents et tout simplement les
assumer nous attendons effectivement
beaucoup des entreprises nous attendons
beaucoup d'elle puisque nous
construisons aujourd'hui un système qui
permet à la fois de mieux prendre en
compte l'emploi des seniors nous pouvons
construire des indicateurs nous pouvons
faciliter les transitions mais pour que
l'emploi des seniors soit au rendez-vous
de cette réforme au rendez-vous du plein
d'emploi il faut aussi un changement
dans l'attitude des dirigeants de celles
et ceux qui gèrent les ressources
humaines pour faire en sorte que les
seniors soient vu comme une compétence
comme un atout plutôt que comme un coup
et en particulier un coup salariale nous
avons aussi besoin de l'engagement des
entreprises sur les questions de
prévention de pénibilité de prévention
de l'usure et là aussi c'est le dialogue
social que nous voulons retenir comme
méthode pour permettre justement la mise
en place de plan de prévention qui soit
des plans massifs permettant tout
simplement à des salariés d'aller
jusqu'au bout de leur carrière sans être
abîmé par leur travail ça doit être
cassé par le labeur et devoir partir
plus tôt justement parce que leur
organisme a été détecter nous faisons
aussi en sorte de mobiliser les
entreprises pour que l'ensemble de cette
réforme puisse être mené avec la
progressivité nécessaire que beaucoup
appel de leur vœu et la volonté de
retrouver un équilibre nous le faisons
enfin et c'est peut-être là aussi le
gage de confiance qui s'est noué avec
nos interlocuteurs représentant des
différentes strates d'entreprise nous le
faisons en cohérence avec la politique
économique et d'un autre est-ce que nous
mettons en oeuvre comme réforme des
retraites est une réforme qui n'est pas
contradictoire avec notre politique de
compétitivité nous continuerons à
diminuer le coût du travail
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est au président Chassaigne pour
le groupe Ghost démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
vous allez nous annoncer dans quelques
heures le contenu de votre réforme des
retraites négocié avec les républicains
une réforme brutale une réforme de
droite vous prétextez pour la justifier
une urgence la faillite de notre régime
de retraite quelle urgence un déficit
pour les 10 années à venir qui loin de
mettre en péril notre régime de retraite
pourrait être facilement résorbé rien
rien sur le plan économique ne justifie
un recul le l'âge de départ à la
retraite rien sauf votre enfermement
idéologique nous vous demandons donc de
renoncer à votre texte qui pénalisera
tous les travailleurs et aggravera les
injustices existantes si vous persistez
un dépit du bon sens nous nous ont
imaginé que vous nous empêcherez dans
des battre madame la Première ministre
que vous nous empêcherez de faire des
propositions pour améliorer notre
système de retraite par répartition
c'est pourtant ce que vous ferez si vous
choisissez de présenter votre réforme
via un bel FSS rectificatif une manœuvre
grossière une manœuvre digne d'ennemis
de la démocratie une manœuvre permettant
de profiter des délais constitutionnels
imposés par son examen et empêcher ainsi
les oppositions de mettre en débat leur
proposition de réforme sous peine de
voir votre projet mise en oeuvre pour
ordonnance il faudra l'expliquer aux
françaises et aux Français madame de
Première ministre et assumer leur dire
que vous leur refusez le temps du débat
démocratique car vous en avez peur peur
de l'opposition unanime de tous les
syndicats et de près de 85% de la
population à travailler plus longtemps
cette confiscation du débat serait un
nouveau coup un coup terrible pour notre
démocratie à rebours nous portons
l'étendard de la démocratie pour décider
de l'avenir de nos retraites renoncez à
votre réforme oui renoncez votre effort
ma défaut nous porterons l'exigence d'un
référendum pour que ce soit au peuple au
final qui tranche merci monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
merci Madame après Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Chassaigne
je pense que nous pouvons être d'accord
sur un point la retraite par répartition
est au cœur de notre contrat social
elle est au fondement de la solidarité
entre les générations mais aujourd'hui
comme le montre le rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites et comme le
constate nos concitoyens eux-mêmes le
nombre d'actifs par rapport au nombre de
retraités ne cesse de diminuer cela a
des conséquences que chacun connaît les
déficits s'accumulent et nous devons
agir vite et c'est bien ce que le
président de la République apporté lors
de sa campagne nous avons été clair avec
les Français
alors depuis des mois nous menons une
concertation intense avec le ministre
Olivier du sotte avec les partenaires
sociaux tout sont participés aux
échanges avec les gros politiques et
j'ai rencontré à plusieurs reprises les
présidents de tous les groupes
parlementaires et je voudrais vous
remercier monsieur le Président Chassel
comme l'ensemble de vos collègues à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat car chacune des
rencontres même lorsque nous sommes en
désaccord a été utile pour faire
progresser le projet nous avons montré
par le passé monsieur le Président que
nous pouvions trouver des points
d'accord nous l'avons vu sur votre
proposition de loi pour revaloriser les
retraites agricoles donc monsieur le
Président Chassaigne avec le ministre
Olivier du soft nous aurons l'occasion
dans les prochaines heures de présenter
notre projet pour les retraites je
voudrais devant vous revenir sur
quelques grands principes d'abord nous
voulons un projet qui finance les
retraites et rien d'autre que les
retraites nous refusons d'augmenter le
coût du travail ou les impôts nous
refusons de baisser les pensions au
contraire nous voulons les augmenter
nous voulons un retour à l'équilibre de
notre système à l'horizon 2030 c'est
pourquoi pour l'avenir de nos retraites
nous devrons progressivement travailler
plus longtemps mais ça n'est pas tout
nous portons un projet de justice en
tenant compte des carrières longues en
tenant compte de la pénibilité de
certains métiers en s'assurant que le
même métier donne la même retraite nous
défendons un projet porteur de progrès
social nous augmenterons la pension
minimale pour les futurs retraités après
de 1200 euros nets par mois nous
redonnerons toute leur place alors aux
salariés proches de la retraite dans les
entreprises alors monsieur le Président
Chassagne comme je l'ai déjà indiqué ce
projet de loi sera présenté en Conseil
des ministres le 23 janvier il sera
ensuite débattu dans votre assemblée je
que les députés de laupes ont beaucoup
parlé de démocratie ces dernières
semaines j'espère que les actes suivront
les mots j'espère que le débat pourra se
dérouler dans les meilleures conditions
sans obstruction autour d'un débat de
fond et d'idées je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Présidente Le
Pen pour le groupe rassemblement
national
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la première ministre il y a
un an lorsque vous étiez ministre du
Travail vous aviez commandé le rapport
RL pour la reconnaissance des métiers de
deuxième ligne ces métiers que l'on ne
peut pas exercer à distance sur
lesquelles la France est reposée durant
la crise covid conducteur agent
d'entretien caissier ouvrier de la
manutention ou encore charcutier et bien
sûr boulanger l'objectif était alors de
revaloriser ces métiers absolument
essentiels à la vie de la nation vous
voici à Matignon et comme le rappelle
France Info 80% des boulangers risquent
la faillite et c'est désormais en
première ligne que vous les laissez face
aux énergéticiens pour renégocier leur
contrat
pour stopper cette flambée des prix de
l'électricité ça devrait être à vous
d'être en première ligne pour enfin
renégocier les clauses du marché
européen d’énergie en dissociant le prix
du gaz de celui de l'électricité
à l'image de nos boulangers plus
largement de nos artisans et commerçants
en ce début d'année 2023 une grande
partie de nos compatriotes sont fatigués
un Français sur deux se dit révolter
face à la situation économique du pays
et près de 8 Français sur dix craignent
une explosion sociale un niveau jamais
enregistré depuis 24 ans alors dans ce
contexte pensez-vous sincèrement madame
la Première ministre qu'il est bon pour
le pays de débuter cette année en nous
proposant tout à l'heure une réforme des
retraites en vue de décaler l'âge de
départ à la retraite à laquelle 70% des
Français sont opposés le gouvernement
parle de courage mais ça n'est pas du
courage de faire payer aux Français et
en particulier à ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt les échecs des politiques
de ces dernières pour pérenniser notre
modèle de retraite il faut d'une part
relancer la natalité et d'autre part
créer des emplois de qualité pour enfin
relancer la productivité de notre
économie
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
madame la Présidente Le Pen alors je
vous confirme madame la Présidente que
notre objectif l'objectif de mon
gouvernement c'est de protéger des
Français c'est de les protéger face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie c'est le
sens du bouclier tarifaire c'est le sens
des mesures pour les entreprises pour
les collectivités que nous avons porté
dès cet été dans le paquet pouvoir
d'achat et dans les textes financiers
adoptés à la fin de l'année et je note
madame la Présidente que le
rassemblement national a voté contre
tous ces textes donc malgré le
rassemblement national malgré le
rassemblement national nous pouvons
proposer un amortisseur pour baisser la
facture d'électricité des Français dans
le cadre de la loi de finances nous
pouvons proposer des aides financées par
la marge dégagée par les fournisseurs
d'énergie et c'est ce que nous faisons
le ministre de l'Économie a eu
l'occasion de rappeler l'ensemble des
dispositifs qui sont mis en oeuvre pour
protéger nos boulangers nos artisans nos
très petites entreprises des 7 semaines
nous artisans peuvent s'adresser en
préfecture pour notamment avoir accès à
l'ensemble des aides qui permettent de
prendre en charge jusqu'à 40 % de la
hausse de la facture d'électricité tous
ceux dont les tarifs sont supérieurs à
280 euros du mégawattheure auront une
nouvelle proposition de leur
fournisseurs d'électricité et par
ailleurs madame la Présidente nous
protégeons notre économie nous
protégeons les Français aujourd'hui mais
nous protégeons aussi l'avenir des
Français l'avenir de nos retraites et
c'est le sens du projet de justice
d'équilibre et de solidarité que je
présenterai dans les prochaines heures
je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Madame Marie le bec pour
le comprenaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre alors que la conjoncture
économique reste difficile avec la
permanence de la guerre en Ukraine la
réouverture économique des ordonnées de
la Chine ou encore l'instabilité des
prix de l'énergie notre économie résiste
les résultats sont là une croissance
positive à 2,5% en 2022 le cap du
million d'entreprises créées 300 000
emplois créés sur les trois premiers
trimestres de 2022 dont 62000 emplois
industriel net elle résiste grâce à
l'engagement de tous au premier rang
desquels nos entrepreneurs et leurs
salariés je tiens ici à saluer leur
persévérance et leur résilience alors
que le contexte national européen et
international aurait pu les décourager
d'investir et d'innover mais également
grâce à la réactivité du gouvernement et
de l'ensemble des services déconcentrés
de l'État à ce titre l'annonce la
semaine dernière par le Président de la
République de sa volonté de s'appuyer
sur notre réseau de préfecture a été
salué par les acteurs économiques qui
ont en mémoire leur très grande
réactivité durant la crise du covid
ainsi qu'à l'occasion du déploiement du
plan de relance le bouclier énergétique
met en place par notre majorité tout
comme le guichet d'aide complété par
l'amortisseur de l'électricité ont été
des premières réponses ils ont permis de
protéger la très grande majorité de nos
PME éligibles au tarif régulé néanmoins
aucun de nous ici sur ces bandes a été
sous aux appels de nos boulangers de nos
bouchers de nos restaurateurs quant aux
difficultés croissantes qu'ils pouvaient
rencontrer face à l'augmentation de leur
facture or ils sont parfois les derniers
acteurs économiques de nos centres
villes
par ailleurs monsieur le ministre depuis
plusieurs années vous êtes vous avez
engagé une bataille en faveur de la
réindustrialisation de notre pays nous
l'avons vu depuis 5 ans déjà la France
est devenue le premier pays européen en
termes d'attractivité l'industrie est
une condition nécessaire pour faire de
notre pays une nation puissante et
souveraine pareil nous croyons dans la
majorité comme au gouvernement la
capacité de notre industrie à ce verdir
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre de les l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques doivent désormais être
mobilisés pour agir en faveur de la
réussite économique de notre pays seuls
l'État ne peut rien si ces batailles
économiques sont d'immenses défis pour
l'année à venir elle ne doivent pas nous
faire oublier les bons résultats que
nous connaissons depuis 5 ans aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
dire quels sont les perspectives
économiques pour 2023 merci beaucoup
madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
mesdames la députée le bec
avant la coupure de Noël certains nous
expliquer que nous allions entrer en
récession
que la production industrielle allait
s'effondrer que le chômage allait
repartir à la hausse et que nous aurions
des coupures d'électricité cet hiver
faute de réacteurs nucléaires
[Musique]
oui c'était vous
le résultat
c'est que aujourd'hui nous avons une
croissance de 2,5% en 2022 que la
croissance 2023 sera positive que
l'indice de la production industrielle
en novembre a été positive à nouveau et
que nous avons continué à créer au
dernier trimestres des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois en France qu'il n'y a
pas eu de coupure d'électricité et que
au contraire les ingénieurs les ouvriers
les salariés d'EDF viennent de remettre
aujourd'hui en état les 45 gigawatts
qu'ils avaient promis pour la mi-janvier
nous sommes le 10 janvier les 45
gigawatts ont été remis sur le réseau
par les salariés par les ingénieurs par
les ouvriers par les soudeurs d'EDF
alors oui la France résiste oui
l'économie française résiste oui la
croissance française résiste et résiste
même mieux que celle de ses partenaires
et donc il faut poursuivre dans cette
dynamique là nous vous proposons dans
les mois qui viennent un projet de loi
de l'industrialisation verte vous avez
déjà vous êtes majorité réussie à créer
61 000 emplois industriels net au cours
du précédent quinquennat c'est la
première fois depuis des décennies que
la France recrée des emplois industriels
et rouvrent des usines et bien avec ce
projet de loi d'industrie verte nous
allons à nouveau accélérer cette
industrialisation de la nation française
pour faire de la France la première
nation décarbonée de l'Union européenne
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Arthur de la porte
pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
la première ministre
c'est l'histoire d'un projet de décret
sur l'assurance chômage transmis aux
partenaires sociaux le 23 décembre
tout simplement l'histoire banale de
votre mépris du dialogue social mais
c'est aussi
l'histoire secrète de votre secrétespoir
qu'un plus grand durcissement de votre
réforme passe inaperçu vous vouliez en
catimini réduire quasiment de moitié
l'indemnisation avec un taux de chômage
à moins de 6%. dans le contexte
économique et social que nous
connaissons alors même que l'assurance
chômage affichera un excédent de 3
milliards d'euros en 2023 vous étiez
donc prêt à être à sacrifier un nombre
croissants plus important nos
concitoyens joli cadeau de Noël mais ce
secrétespoir a été déçu et vous avez
donc fait semblant de reculer pour mieux
conserver votre terrible réforme car
votre réforme antisocial toujours aussi
dur et violent doit entrer en oeuvre
dans trois petites semaines une baisse
seulement de 25% des droits 6 mois de
moins pour les travailleurs de moins de
55 ans 8 mois de moins pour les plus de
55 ans votre baisse brutale va donc
s'appliquer de manière encore plus
violente pour les seniors ces
travailleurs en fin de carrière
avec votre réforme des retraites
annoncées ce soir c'est la double peine
moins d'indemnités plus de précarité dès
demain mais avec le recul de l'âge de
départ que vous promettez c'est aussi
plus de seniors sans allocations au
chômage ni retraite alors qu'environ on
l'a dit tout à l'heure près d'une
personne sur deux de plus de 55 ans et
sans emploi ce régime est ignoble il
faudra donc le subir deux ans de plus
pour toucher une retraite réduite à
portion congrue car faut-il le rappeler
le chômeur cotise pour sa retraite celui
qui n'a pas d'allocation ne cotise pas
vos prétendus réformes c'est donc
toujours plus de précarité pour ceux qui
ont moins rappelons qu'en novembre 58
000 personnes ont été rasées de Pôle
Emploi un record absolu mais il n'est
pas trop tard pour plus de justice pour
la raison abroger l'assurance chômage et
garder votre projet de retraite au
placard merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre de
l'Emploi dans du travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion merci Madame donc
Monsieur le Député de la porte il nous
semble parfois que vous trouvez
satisfaisante une situation dans
laquelle effectivement un Français de
plus de 50 ans sur deux serait sur le
marché du travail une situation dans
laquelle
l'emploi des seniors serait finalement
laissé de côté nous menons une politique
d'emploi et le ministre de l'Économie
vient de l'évoquer limite une politique
de l'emploi qui porte ses fruits au
troisième trimestre de l'année 2022 ce
sont 119 000 emplois qui ont été créés
112 119 000 en planète et plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'emplois sont
encore créés au quatrième trimestre
entre le mois d'octobre 2021 et le mois
d'octobre 2022 pour prendre une seule
année la plante de réduction des
tensions la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi que nous avons mis en oeuvre
par Pôle emploi a permis de raccompagner
vers l'emploi 380 000 demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée dans presque
200000 étaient des demandeurs d'emploi
de très longue durée c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour eux c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les entreprises nous avons
un taux de chômage qui est
historiquement bas et nous avons
effectivement porter une réforme de
l'assurance chômage du marché du travail
qui permet d'intégrer la conjoncture
économique dans la définition des règles
d'indemnisation avec la volonté d'avoir
des règles plus incitatives quand il y a
des tensions de recrutement et des
créations d'emplois comme aujourd'hui et
des règles plus protectrices comme nous
l'avons montré pendant la période de
covid lorsque nous avons prolongé les
droits de ceux qui arrivent en fin de
droit en période de confinement ou
encore mise en place une année blanche
pour les intermittents du spectacle nous
avons un décret un décret qui est encore
d'examen qui sera effectivement en
vigueur à partir du 1er février et qui
pose la première brique pour l'année
2023 de cette politique de contrat
cyclicité nous avons dit aux partenaires
sociaux notre volonté que ce mouvement
de contractilité puisse aller plus loin
et parce que cela a été dit peut-être
trop tardivement nous avons fait le
choix de ne pas le laisser de ne pas
l'intégrer au décret tel qu'il est
présenté au Conseil d'État nous avons un
nombre de chantiers devant nous premier
chantier c'est la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage dans quelques
semaines je ne resterai au partenaire
sociaux le document d'orientation leur
permettant de travailler sur la place de
l'État et donc du Parlement sur le rôle
du paritarisme pour la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage et une fois cet
accord j'espère trouver nous aurons à
nouveau à saisir les partenaires sociaux
pour travailler sur la question des
modalités d'indemnisation à partir 2024
bien évidemment dans ce cadre là la
contracyclicité sera un angle merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
valtoux pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
François Brune ministre de la santé et
de la prévention vendredi dernier le
président de la République a lancé le
grand chantier de la réforme de notre
système de santé un chantier aux
multiples facettes mais dont l'urgence
et la nécessité ne sont plus à démontrer
nous le constatons tous les jours sur le
terrain et dans la difficulté les
hospitaliers sont au premier horloges et
je leur dire depuis ces banques toute ma
solidarité mon plein soutien après un
effort inédit sur les rémunérations avec
les accords de Ségur et la relance de
l'investissement hospitalier il s'agit
maintenant de refonder totalement un
système de santé en crise profonde
parmi les principaux objectifs figurent
la difficile question de la remise à
plat de son financement à la fois pour
sortir de la tarification à l'activité
mais aussi pour valoriser la pertinence
des soins déjà en septembre 2018 le
président de la République avait
lui-même rappelé en lançant la réforme
ma santé 2022 que 30 % des dépenses de
santé étaient dépenses inutiles indus ou
non pertinentes et qu'une régulation
plus ferme était nécessaire je partage
ce constat depuis longtemps le modèle de
financement du financement à l'activité
comme l'alpha et l'oméga du financement
à la fois du système hospitalier des
soins de ville à abouti à des excès et
ce autant à l'hôpital où la tarification
à l'activité représente la moitié des
financements que dans le secteur privé
où ça part est beaucoup plus élevé
la France consacre rappelons-le 270
milliards d'euros à ses dépenses de
santé si l'on considère 30% de dépenses
non pertinentes sur cet ensemble il y a
largement de quoi mieux financer et la
consultation 25 euros du généraliste et
les rémunérations des Hospitaliers comme
celle de l'ensemble de nos
professionnels percutés par la crise
sanitaire et la nécessité de se
concentrer sur l'accompagnement des
Hospitaliers pendant cette période cette
réforme du financement n'a pas été faite
mais elle arrive enfin enfin et tant
mieux aussi Monsieur le Ministre j'ai
deux questions en remplacement la
tarification à l'activité quel modèle de
financement envisagez-vous pour la
pérennité nos établissements de santé
par ailleurs comment allez-vous
concrétiser cette nécessité voir cette
urgence de mieux réguler par la
pertinence ce que la France consacre à
son système de santé merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur François ministre
de la Santé de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Valtou le discours du 6 janvier
du président de la République devant les
soignants Marc est concrétise un
changement de méthode et même d'analyse
par rapport au problème de notre système
de santé vous le savez notre système de
santé a été construit sur l'offre de
soins qui est par définition
concurrentielle et qui s'appuie sur un
financement effectivement à l'acte le
changement de cap c'est retravailler
notre système de santé sur la base de la
réponse aux besoins de santé de la
population alors trois mots d'ordre
simplifiés décloisonner valoriser mais
valoriser à la réalisation des missions
de santé publique de chaque partenaire
au niveau de l'hôpital quelques éléments
clés revenir à l'échelle du service en
tout cas pour les services qui le
souhaitent sortir de cette logique de
pôles et de mégapole mais revenir à une
taille humaine le partage de la
pénibilité de la nuit doit être réalisé
entre tous les partenaires il n'est pas
normal
que l'un des partenaires supporte seul
toute la pénibilité des gardes et des
arts craintes de la même façon nous
allons mettre en place un suivi de la
carrière de l'ensemble des soignants
suivis de la carrière pour que quand on
entre comme infirmière dans un hôpital
on est des perspectives d'avenir allez
éventuellement vers des responsabilités
reconnaître ses compétences créer ces
nouveaux métiers que sont les infirmiers
en pratique avancés c'est également
valable pour les praticiens hospitaliers
dans l'ensemble de leurs missions la
coopération territoriale va être la base
de cette refonte du système de santé le
partage de compétences le partage de
missions entre les différents
partenaires
en fait c'est valable également pour le
financement puisque nous passons donc de
cette logique de financement de l'offre
la T2A a un financement de réponse aux
besoins qui sera populationnel pour
répondre aux besoins de chaque
territoire qui sera sur la pertinence
des soins qui sera sur la qualité des
soins et bien sûr quelques éléments
encore sur la qualité il faut mettre de
l'humain remettre du bon sens dans les
organisations et dans le financement
pour le public comme pour le privé nous
aurons l'occasion dans cette assemblée
dans des battre lors du PLFSS de l'année
prochaine monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe lotiau pour le
contrat rassemblement national
madame madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
depuis que ton performances scolaire
diminue notre pays éprouve des
difficultés tel était le constat du
candidat Emmanuel Macron dans son
programme de 2017 or les résultats de
l'évaluation récente des élèves rentrant
en 6e en septembre 2022 vous ont amené à
reconnaître dans une tribune que je cite
les comparaisons internationales
révèlent des lacunes préoccupante et
pour cause cette évaluation illustre que
plus du quart des élèves maîtrise mal
voire très mal le français et plus du
tiers les mathématiques ceci dans la
droite ligne de toutes les études
internationales le niveau constaté en
France ne fait que baisser et se situe
sensiblement de ça de la moyenne
européenne et de celle de l'OCDE or les
élèves rentrant en 6e à la rentrée de
septembre sont ceux qui rentraient en
cours préparatoire en septembre 2017 le
constat s'impose de lui-même la
présidence d'Emmanuel Macron et bien
celle de la poursuite de l’affessement
de l'école républicaine
une école où l'autorité des maîtres a
disparu une école gangrenée par le
woquisme les expérimentations
pédagogiques hasardeuses le
communautarisme la repentance et région
principe d'éducation tous aussi rend
impossible à transmission d'une histoire
d'un savoir des principes fondamentaux
qui assurent à la fois l'instruction et
l'assimilation de tous nos enfants la
preuve en est le croisement inégalités
sociales peut être pour cause de
sobriété énergétiques mais l'esprit des
Lumières ne brille plus guère d'un
renseignement primaire alors que vous
reconnaissez-vous même que l'accent doit
être mis sur les savoirs fondamentaux
que proposez-vous un renforcement de
l'accompagnement des élèves en 6e or le
cycle d'apprentissages fondamentaux est
entre le CP le CE2 c'est là que les
élèves acquérupa les notions
indispensables à leur avenir c'est là
que les efforts doivent être portés en
priorité monsieur le ministre revenir au
fondamentaux dès le primaire n'est pas
une mission impossible beaucoup
d'enseignants dévoilent il faut juste
une volonté au-delà des discours aussi
pour éviter que la dégradation du niveau
se poursuivre allez-vous enfin agir pour
l'enseignement primaire et comment je
vous remercie beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur pas pendji ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
madame madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
l'audio en effet il faut le dire comme
elles le sont j'ai indiqué que les
résultats de nos élèves en ce qui
concerne les savoirs fondamentaux ne
sont pas à la hauteur cela comprend
également et cela doit se lire en
perspective des années précédentes et
notamment de la crise sanitaire qui a
fortement impacté les résultats de
l'école primaire dans les évaluations de
6e pour remédier à cette situation que
nous reconnaissons j'ai annoncé des
mesures fortes à la hauteur de ces
constats aux primaires des
recommandations cette semaine vont être
adressées aux professeur au formateur et
aux inspecteurs afin que soient instauré
partout dans la foulée d'un rapport de
l'Inspection générale la pratique
régulière de la dictée la pratique
quotidienne de la rédaction le temps
hebdomadaire d'écrit et certainement
insuffisants en cours moyen et enfin la
régularité du calcul mental une autre
conclusion de l'inspection générale au
collège nous agissons dès la rentrée
prochaine sur la rentrée de 6e en
facilitant la transition entre le
primaire et le secondaire pour
s'attaquer immédiatement aux difficultés
des élèves afin que ces difficultés ne
pèsent pas sur l'ensemble de la
scolarité au collège pour cet effet
chaque élève bénéficiera d'une heure de
soutien en français et en mathématiques
assurée par des professeurs des écoles
en 6e de manière à remédier à ces
difficultés par ailleurs le dispositif
devoir fait sera rendu obligatoire pour
tous les élèves de 6e et je mentionne
enfin la généralisation et l'obligation
de leur ennemi de mathématiques pour les
élèves de Première nous agissons donc
pour pour les savoirs fondamentaux de
manière très concrète afin d'améliorer
les résultats de nos élèves pour leur
pour leur vie scolaire et pour le
résultat merci merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame Sophie tailler polluant
pour le groupe écologiste merci madame
la Présidente dans son rapport en
septembre dernier le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites écrit
clairement qu'il n'y a pas d'urgence
notre système de retraite véritable
joyau de notre protection sociale n'est
pas en danger essayez de convaincre les
Français d'avaler votre recul des
retraites au nom d'un soi-disant
sauvetage du système c'est leur mentir
votre unique obsession est de trouver
qui va payer le quoi qu'il en coûte
ainsi que votre politique fiscale faite
pour les plus riches et avec vous c'est
toujours pareil le peuple doit payer car
le recul de l'âge de départ est une
mesure qui va de fait fragilisée le plus
grand nombre les Français le savent bien
qui sont opposés à cette réforme à 85%,
pas bien que les propositions que vous
allez formuler vont fragiliser les
femmes les personnes aux carrières
fragmentées et vont faire perdre à
toutes et tous deux ou trois belles
années de retraite qui est pourtant de
Françaises et de Français sont les seuls
qu'ils vivront en bonne santé il n'y a
aucune urgence à réformer notre système
de retraite si ce n'est pour l'améliorer
et de multiples pistes sont sur la table
pour financer cela aussi le choix qui
s'annonce de faire passer cette
régression via un
plfssr est un nouveau palier que vous
vous apprêtez à franchir dans le mépris
du Parlement et de la démocratie car
qu'est-ce qu'un
plfssr et bien comme son nom l'indique
c'est un texte pour rectifier des
propositions budgétaires qui s'avèrent
inexactes et c'est pas le cas ici vous
choisissez cette option uniquement pour
limiter le débat parlementaire cette
procédure ouvre même la possibilité de
passer par ordonnance en tout cas dans
l'ismant alors on pensait qu’après 10
49-3 on avait tout vu bien non
l'innovation au pouvoir avec vous
décidément vous êtes très fort c'est un
véritable détournement de l'esprit de la
Constitution renoncer à cette méthode
renoncer à cette réforme
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
si madame la présidente madame la
députée Sophie taipolion vous nous
demandez madame la député si il y a
urgence je le dis il y a urgence et le
rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites composé des partenaires
sociaux posent trois constats que je
partage à nouveau avec vous ne
désespérons pas finalement d'emporter
votre adhésion premier constat c'est
qu'à la fin des années 70 nous avions
trois cotisants pour un retraité au
début des années 2000 nous avons deux
cotisons pour un retraité aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 1,7 cotisants pour un
retraité et en 2040 nous aurons 1,4
cotisants pour un retraité c'est ça
madame la député le problème
démographique c'est ça qui explique que
nous devons travailler un peu plus c'est
ça qui explique l'essentiel du déficit
qui est tout ce constaté deuxième
constat que je partage avec vous vous
l'avez vous même cité que dit le rapport
du corps
il dit que le système est très
légèrement excédentaire cette année
l'année dernière il dit que dès 2023 ce
système sera déficitaire et qu'en 2027
c'est 12 milliards et demi de déficit
par an qui sont déficitaires c'est 15
milliards de rangs 2030 c'est 25
milliards d'euros en 2040 si vous
considérez que 25 milliards c'est rien
nous n'avons pas la même conviction la
même conception de l'ordre des grandeurs
et puis enfin le rapport du corps il dit
une troisième chose qui devrait vous
alerter il dit que si nous ne faisons
rien le niveau de vie relatif des
retraités va s'effondrer est-ce que
c'est ce que vous voulez est-ce que vous
voulez retrouver la situation des années
70 dans les retraités n'étaient pauvres
de ce pays alors même que le système
para répartition a permis de redresser
de consolider leur pouvoir d'achat nous
allons mener pour cette réforme pour
éviter ces trois écueils nous allons
mener cette réforme pour faire en sorte
que justement les carrières hachées les
plus fragiles les femmes puissent avoir
des mesures qui les protègent mieux
qu'aujourd'hui ces cinq nous faisons je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure nous améliorons
parce que c'est important d'améliorer
nous équilibrons parce que c'est
raisonnable et qui sans améliorer c'est
injuste améliorer sans équilibrer ses
responsable nous allons faire les deux
je te remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Charlotte Parmentier
le coq pour le groupe Renaissance merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
santé et de la prévention monsieur le
ministre lors de ses vœux aux acteurs de
la santé le président de la République a
annoncé la fin tant espérer de la
tarification à l'acte la même qui a
provoqué une désorganisation majeure de
nos hôpitaux en faisant primer la
rentabilité sur l'intérêt des patients
je salue cette initiative qui s'inscrit
dans l'action de notre majorité et
s'ajoutera à la suppression du numerus
clausus bien sûr mais également à la
revalorisation de la rémunération et à
l'augmentation du nombre de soignants
nous devons poursuivre sur cette voie et
je salue la proposition de loi de notre
collègue Stéphanie riste qui apporte une
avancée supplémentaire en permettant
l'accès direct aux infirmiers en
pratiquants
thérapeute et aux orthophonistes dans le
cadre d'un exercice coordonné avec les
médecins généralistes
dégager du temps médical est
indispensable monsieur le ministre tous
les professionnels de santé sont
unanimes il faut tailler à la hache dans
les lourds de la administrative
alourdissant uniquement leur travail
monsieur le ministre les soignants mais
aussi les passions compte sur nous aussi
quels sont vos échéances dans la
concrétisation de la feuille de route
tracée par le Président de la République
je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur François brode
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
parmentier de coq le 6 janvier dernier
le président de la République a
effectivement tracé un cap une feuille
de route nouvelle pour la refondation de
notre système de santé beaucoup a déjà
été fait mais nous devons aller plus
loin plus vite pour répondre aux défis
qui sont devant nous des axes forts
régler les problèmes à l'échelle de
chaque territoire sortir d'une logique
concurrentielle travailler en
coopération retrouver des collectifs à
échelle humaine redonner du temps
médical plus largement du temps de soins
est un enjeu majeur comme la préciser le
président de la République il a
disparition trop tardive du numerus
clausus n'aura défait que dans 5 à 10
ans alors comment faire
en laissant les soignants faire ce
pourquoi ils sont formés le soin en
ville en développant en continuant à
développer des assistants médicaux créés
lors du précédent quinquennat et à
l'hôpital en intégrant les
administratives des logisticiens au plus
près des soignants dans les services
en utilisant mieux les compétences de
chacun la plus-value de chaque
professionnel notamment au sein d'une
équipe traitante autour du médecin
traitant nous avons et nous allons
continuer à travailler dans cet axe avec
le projet de loi de la rapporteur
Stéphanie Rist ce sont une finale des
engagements clairs pour les Français un
médecin traitant pour tous ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin les gens en affection
de longue durée avant la fin de l'année
une continuité université des soins sur
tous les territoires ce sont aussi des
engagements clairs pour les
professionnels de santé pour suivre la
meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité du travail de nuit des
objectifs au niveau des organisations de
qualité de qualité de vie au travail et
enfin construire des pactes avec les
élus pour l'attractivité des territoires
sur engagement les crèches et les
transports les échanges sont courtes car
l'enjeu est majeur mars 2023 pour la fin
des négociations avec les médecins
libéraux joint 2023 pour l'hôpital ce
qui sera important pour moi c'est des
résultats objectifs réels auprès des
français auprès des soignants soyez
assurés que je suis totalement déterminé
ainsi que mon ministère pour avancer en
ce sens je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame Parmentier Lecoq oui
merci madame la Présidente comme il me
reste un petit peu de temps
permettez-moi également monsieur Miss de
vous convier à la maison de santé de
Templeuve-en-Pévèle ou grâce à
l'engagement des soignants des acteurs
économiques du maire de la commune et à
la confiance accordée par la RS nous
inaugurons prochainement l'implantation
du premier scanner en France au sein
d'une maison de santé
je vous remercie madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre
trois crises angoisses en cette rentrée
nos concitoyens sur chacune d'entre
elles
la santé le prix de l'électricité les
retraites vous soufflez sur les braises
et vous refusez de prendre les décisions
qui allégeraient la souffrance des
Français sur la santé vous annoncez 6000
assistants médicaux fantômes mais vous
refusez de réintégrer 15000 soignants
scandaleusement exclus qui pourraient
être au chevet des malades comme dans
tous les pays du monde sur le prix de
l'électricité sur le prix de
l'électricité vous multipliez les
dispositifs complexes bureaucratiques
insuffisant alors qu'il faudrait
simplement comme l'on fait l'Espagne le
Portugal revenir un prix national
aligné sur les coups de production qui
permettrait de sauver nos PME nos
boulangers nos artisans mais vous le
refusez
enfin sur les retraites vous allez
plonger dans la misère bon nombre de
seniors qui n'auront pas d'emploi entre
62 et 64 ans qui seront au minima
sociaux alors tout ça pour quelques
milliards en 2030 alors qu'en revanche
vous refusez de vous attaquer au
dizaines de milliards de fraudes
sociales de fraude fiscale au versement
de l'Union européenne au coût de
l'immigration clandestine alors ma
question est très simple en cette début
d'année pourquoi continuer à mettre de
l'huile sur le feu à faire souffrir les
Français à diviser la nation
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier Béran
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les députés en ce début
d'année je vous dis monsieur
Dupont-Aignan en ce début d'année
certains parmi nous on fait comme le
veut la tradition des voeux d'autres ont
pris des bonnes résolutions
manifestement 2023 ne sera pas l'année
au cours de laquelle vous prendrez la
bonne résolution d'arrêter pour de bon
la démagogie
[Applaudissements]
vous savez que j'aime bien répondre sur
le fond aux questions qui sont posées
mais en l'occurrence vous avez fait un
espèce de gloubiboulga ou un fond de
cuve de ce qui anime les réseaux
complotistes que peut compter notre pays
ok il sera difficile de vous répondre
sur la totalité des aspects que vous
avez soulevé qui va de la réintégration
des soignants non vaccinés à la retraite
des intendants je ne serai en passant
par je ne sais quoi ce qui est sûr
monsieur le député pour reprendre vos
propres propos les crises angoisses les
Français presque tous les Français pas
vous vous en repaissez
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Dupont-Aignan
monsieur le ministre non donc la parole
est à Madame Bénédicte taurine pour le
groupe la France insoumise je vous
remercie
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
ministre de l'Économie depuis plusieurs
mois nous sommes tout et tous alerté sur
les problématiques de l'organation des
prix de l'énergie dans des secteurs
aussi diversifiés que celui de
l'artisanat avec notamment une
mobilisation inédite des boulangers ou
débouchés celui de l'entreprise ou des
collectivités territoriales votre
gouvernement a mis en oeuvre diverses
mesures je pense par exemple au chèque
énergie ou bouclier un tarifaire et vous
les avez déjà évoqué au cours de cette
séance mais malheureusement ce que l'on
peut constater c'est qu'elle laisse un
nombre très important de personnes ou
d'entreprises sur le bord du chemin
un simple exemple 80% des boulangers
selon leur Confédération ne seraient pas
éligibles au bouclier tarifaires
concernant les entreprises des pays
France précisent que pour 65 000 d'entre
elles l'impact de la hausse des coûts va
faire basculer leur résultat en négatif
quant à la majorité des copropriétés ou
des 600 000 logements sociaux qui sont
chauffés par un système collectif
alimenté par du gaz ou de l'électricité
depuis la libéralisation des marchés de
l'énergie ces chauffages collectifs ne
peuvent plus bénéficier des tarifs
réglementés le mécanisme de compensation
qui a été mis
en place et défaillant et n'empêche pas
les hausses de charges spectaculaires
que pouvons-nous pouvons tous constater
sur nos circonscriptions donc monsieur
le ministre plutôt que de mettre en
place au cas par cas des mesures qui au
final sont peu lisibles qui laissent des
situations sans solution et divise les
Français pouvez-vous nous expliquer pour
quelle raison vous ne prenez pas une
mesure unique simple et juste à la fois
pour les ménages les entreprises et les
collectivités qui seraient te remettre
en place simplement le tarif réglementé
je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame député
Dorine merci de votre question vous le
savez je pense que tout le monde le sait
la France et l'Europe font face à un
choc énergétique exceptionnel est-ce que
vous proposez d'instaurer je pense il
est bien compris à bouclier énergétique
pour l'ensemble des acteurs économiques
c'est tout simplement un coup exorbitant
de l'agent magique le retour ou quoi
qu'il en coûte dans des situations où
elle ne serait clairement pas justifié
vous avez parlé de 80000 boulangers au
bord de la faillite vous le savez nous
avez annoncé un certain nombre de
mesures dont jusqu'à vendredi en accord
avec les distributeurs d'énergie un
plafonnement du tarif non seulement pour
les boulangers mais pour l'ensemble des
TPE les deux tiers d'entre elles sont
éligibles au TRV que vous appelez de vos
vœux le tiers qui reste on verra sa
facture plafonnée à 280 euros le
mégawatt nous avons aussi adopté un
certain nombre de mesures pour les PME
pour les grands groupes industriels qui
consomment beaucoup d'énergie Bruno Le
Maire ministre de l'économie et des
finances a eu l'occasion de le rappeler
tout à l'heure la France aujourd'hui et
le pays qui s'en sort le mieux en Europe
face à ce choc énergétique sans égal
depuis les années 70 la production
industrielle est en hausse le chômage
est en baisse les prévisions de
croissance prêle plaid encore pour une
croissance positive en 2022 alors
qu'elle sera négative à peu près partout
en Europe soyons en fiers mesdames et
messieurs les députés tout ceci est en
grande partie le reflet de mesure que
vous avez voté peut-être pas tout le
monde nous allons continuer à protéger
l'économie française mais de grâce
projetons-nous vers l'avant soyons
optimiste soyons volontariste arrêtons
le défaitisme généralisé la France s'en
sort mieux que tout le monde continue
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Josiane Corneloup
pour le groupe les républicains la
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur le ministre la situation
financière des hôpitaux est
particulièrement inquiétante c'est le
cas de mon hôpital local à
Paray-le-Monial mais plus généralement
de tous les hôpitaux publics l'ensemble
des hôpitaux quelle que soit leur taille
doit faire face à des charges qui
augmentent plus vite que leurs recettes
le retour de l'inflation entraîne par
exemple un surcoût de 750 millions
d'euros annuels un nom d'âme fixé pour
2023 à 4% ne permet même pas de faire
face au surcoût généré par l'inflation
des charges générales hôtelière et
énergétiques qui s'envolent à cela
s'ajoute pour les hôpitaux de proximité
qui ne parviennent pas à recruter des
praticiens permanents le recours à des
praticiens intérimaires ce qui
représente là aussi un surcoût élevé
quant à la hausse légitime du point
d'indice de 3,5% des personnels
elle représente une dépense
supplémentaire annuel de 2 milliards
d'euros qui n'a pas été compensé par
l'État avec un encours national de la
dette de 30 milliards d'euros trois fois
plus qu'en 2002 un nombre croissant
d'établissements et dans l'obligation
d'emprunter beaucoup d'hôpitaux sont
également à ce jour amenés à suspendre
le règlement des taxes sur salaire pour
pouvoir payer leurs fournisseurs si je
salue la reprise de la dette
hospitalière par l'État pour 13
milliards et l'affectation de 6
milliards consacrés dans le plan de
relance à l'investissement la situation
des hôpitaux malgré une activité
inégalée est à ce point dégradé que
cette enveloppe globale est totalement
insuffisante pour permettre aux hôpitaux
d'assurer une prise en charge
satisfaisante des patients
quant au personnel il continue de faire
preuve du même et remarquable dévouement
observer lors de la crise sanitaire mais
travaillant dans des conditions très
difficiles ils sont épuisés et au bord
de la rupture cette situation ne peut
plus durer notre système hospitalier a
besoin d'un vaste plan de refondation il
y a urgence vitale
marque noiset qui vous a succédé à la
tête de samu-francurgence évalue à 150
le nombre de patients morts aux urgences
sur des bancales sur le seul mois de
décembre 2022 monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
François Braun ministre de la santé et
de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
cornedos
je vous rejoins lorsque vous saluez le
l'engagement des soignants qui tiennent
encore quotidiennement nos différents
services qui soignent qui sauvent tous
les jours mais qui est effectivement ne
se retrouve plus dans notre système de
santé il travaille dans les conditions
difficiles trop difficiles et il y a
besoin aussi de leur redonner du sens
alors cette crise de l'hôpital que vous
signalez ce n'est pas qu'une crise de
l'hôpital c'est une crise de l'ensemble
de notre système de santé aussi bien en
ville qu'à l'hôpital mais c'est une
crise qui dépasse aussi malheureusement
le cadre de la France et qui touche tous
les pays industrialisés aujourd'hui les
solutions elles sont dans la
simplification dans le retour à l'humain
dans le bon sens je l'ai dit dans les
organisations comme dans les
financements de notre système de santé
et le député Val tout le disait tout à
l'heure 30% du financement dans le cadre
de la T2A serait induit et devrait être
redéployé différemment je ne reviendrai
pas sur ce principe construit sur
l'offre de soins particulièrement
délétère
pour revenir sur la réponse aux besoins
qui eux donneront du sens alors à
l'hôpital comment ville il faut plus de
soignants auprès des malades gagner du
temps de soin reconquérir nos
territoires en redonnant du temps
médecin les reconquérir également en
restructurant notre offre autour des
hôpitaux de proximité vous l'avez cité
mais chacun a sa place chacun apportant
là aussi la plus-value qu'il peut
apporter dans l'organisation organiser
des coopérations entre ces mêmes
hôpitaux de proximité des hôpitaux de
recours et des hôpitaux supplémentaires
également avec la ville avoir une
réponse non pas nationale mais adaptée à
chaque territoire vous avez soulevé le
problème de l'intérim j'y reviens la
limitation de l'intérim a été votée par
cette assemblée l'année dernière je me
suis engagé à prendre le décret qui
limitera l'intérim médical il sera pris
avant le printemps et nous aurons enfin
un intérim qui répond aux besoins n'ont
plus un intérim cannibale qui entraîne
la déstructuration de notre offre de
soins
donc vous le voyez c'est une véritable
volonté de construire des réponses à
l'échelle des territoires de
restructurer le financement de nos
établissements c'est comme cela que nous
arriverons à sortir de la crise actuelle
la parole est un monsieur Nicolas Paco
pour le groupe Renaissance madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègue il fut un temps où c'est un
geste du quotidien que de colère interne
sur une enveloppe ce premier janvier les
Français ont dit adieu au timbre rouge
qui rejoindra bientôt la disquette le
chéquier ou la cabine téléphonique au
roi de ses objets qui ont été le symbole
d'une époque
désormais en lieu et place de la LED
prioritaire c'est un courrier
électronique qui sera adressé au postier
chargé de l'imprimer avant de le
distribuer ce système sert rapide et
efficace et plus écologique à certains
égards ne manquent pas de poser des
questions
monsieur le ministre nous savons que les
services publics de demain ne peuvent
ressembler éternellement à ceux des
années 60 et que pour s'adapter aux
besoins actuels la Poste doit se
réinventer j'ai pu lire ici et là que
l'argent économisé par le remplacement
du timbre rouge doit servir à développer
d'autres services de proximité à l'image
des étapes numériques lieu dédiés à la
formation chez d'ailleurs assisté le
mois dernier à l'inauguration de la
toute première étape numérique du Doubs
au sein du bureau de poste de
Saint-Hippolyte nous le voyons dans nos
circonscriptions les citoyens qui ont le
plus recours au service postal font
partie de ces 23 millions de personnes
encore en difficulté avec le numérique
dès lors comment garantir à chaque
citoyen un accès satisfaisant au service
postal un guichet d'accueil et d'aide à
l'envoi de ses courriers sera-t-il mis
en place au sein des bureaux de poste
par ailleurs comment est garantie la
confidentialité des courriers ainsi
distribués enfin les postiens nous
concitoyens s'inquièrent de la future
expérimentation dans 68 villes de France
de tourner allégée du facteur cette
nouvelle organisation réveille une
crainte fondée celle du recul des
services publics aussi Monsieur le
Ministre j'aimerais que vous puissiez
nous rassurer sur le fait que le passage
au tout numérique ne remettra pas en
cause la mission principale du groupe La
Poste celle de garantir un service de
proximité
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Noël
Barrault ministre de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Nicolas Pacaud vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur les évolutions de la
politique de courrier du groupe La Poste
il n'a pas échappé au gouvernement que
le passage du timbre rouge à la lettre
rouge suscite chez nos concitoyens un
certain nombre d'interrogations et
d'inquiétudes légitimes permettez-moi
tout d'abord de rappeler les deux
constats sur lesquels ça puisse être
évolution de la politique de courrier du
groupe La Poste d'une part les usages de
nos concitoyens ont évolué là où en 2010
ils envoyaient 45 lettres prioritaires
par an il n'en voit plus que 5 par an en
2021 deuxième constat les évolutions
prévues par le groupe La Poste
permettront d'après le groupe La Poste
d'économiser 60 000 tonnes de CO2 par an
soit 25% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre du groupe grâce notamment à
l'arrêt du transport aérien et un
meilleur
remplissage des camions ceci étant dit
permettez-moi de vous donner quelques
éléments qui seront je l'espère de
nature à vous rassurer et à rassurer
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens d'abord
les timbres rouges qui ont été achetés
avant le premier janvier de cette année
continue évidemment à être fonctionnel
deuxièmement le la présence du facteur
est bien maintenu 6 jours sur 7 pour
l'ensemble des activités du groupe La
Poste sur l'ensemble du territoire
troisièmement les agents de la Poste
pourront accompagner vous l'avez évoqué
les concitoyens qui seraient empêchés ou
dans l'impossibilité d'y parvenir à
réaliser leur envoi de courrier
prioritaire
quatrièmement la Poste maintient
évidemment une offre fiable et rapide
dans votre courrier avec la lettre
service plus qui arrive après deux jours
et la lettre verte qui arrive après 3
jours vous le voyez les conditions sont
réunies pour la qualité du service
universel postal merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre la parole est à
madame soumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé on est à bout on n'en peut plus
les gens meurent et on ne peut rien
faire c'est ce que les soignants
répètent depuis des mois dans toute la
France
Martigny Périgueux Lunel Mayenne 5
allait et j'en passe alors que nous
subissons une triple épidémie de
bronchiolite de covid et de grippe
partout en France des services d'urgence
sont contraints de fermer faute de
personnel ce qui reste ouvert son
submergé et non toujours pas de moyens
supplémentaires résultat le syndicat
SAMU urgence de France fait état de 150
personnes qui ont trouvé la mort de
manière inattendue parce qu'ils
attendaient sans être soignés alors
qu'ils étaient aux urgences
cela fait des mois que les soignants
vous alertent qu'il vous disent qu'ils
sont au bord du craquage vous ne les
écoutez pas trop peu nombreux surmener
ils font leur possible au détriment de
leur propre santé mais sans financement
sans recrutement et sans moyens
supplémentaires il ne s'en sortiront pas
le 31 décembre dernier lessiver et puisé
par des cadences intenables et des
conditions de travail inhumaines 55 des
59 infirmiers infirmières
aide-soignantes et soignants des
urgences de Thionville ont été placés en
arrêt maladie depuis hier le mouvement a
été suivi par les soignants des urgences
de Pontoise qui sont 90% à être en arrêt
maladie
cette situation est symptomatique du
sous-financement délibéré de l'hôpital
public et de la libéralisation du
système de soins en France alors
Monsieur le Ministre quand donc
allez-vous écouter les soignants quand
donc allez-vous endiguer la casse de
l'hôpital public en structurant un
système de santé égalitaire et
accessible à tous en constituant un
véritable service public de santé en
réouvrant les services d'urgence en
revalorisant les salaires et ainsi
redonner du sens au travail de nos
soignants
monsieur le ministre combien de morts a
encore avant que vous ne réagissiez
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
santé et de la prévention
madame la Présidente et Messieurs les
Députés madame
la députée Martine Étienne
je ne répondrai pas à votre dernière
remarque et vous le comprendrez vu le
métier que j'ai exercé pendant plus de
30 ans je connais la situation des
services d'urgence je la connais même
bien y compris vous le savez
parfaitement la situation des urgences
de Thionville j'en profite d'ailleurs
sur cette saturation de notre système et
vous parliez de la tripe épidémie pour
rappeler ici encore une fois vous me
direz l'application des gestes barrières
et l'intérêt de la vaccination là aussi
pour lever la pression sur nos services
d'urgence je ne doute pas que tous ici
vous aurez à coeur de lever cette
pression et d'appliquer ces consignes
simples alors mon premier mot sera bien
sûr pour soutenir les gens qui
travaillent dans ses services mes
anciens collègues qui arrivent à tenir à
bout de brun un système mais pour autant
la situation qui est décrite dans
certains services est totalement
inacceptable et je m'assure soit ils ont
certaines de la mobilisation des
directions d'établissements avec les ARS
pour résoudre au plus vite ces
situations que nous pouvons Tol pour
l'accès à la santé de nos concitoyens
nos services d'urgence et vous le savez
aussi sont le réceptacle de nombreux
problèmes de notre système de santé en
amont avec la réponse aux soins non
programmés et en aval avec le manque de
disponibilité de lit pour hospitaliser
des patients face à ces difficultés vous
le savez aussi nous agissons par des
réponses immédiates je vais pas revenir
sur les mesures de l'été dans un certain
nombre sont prolongés sur l'accentuation
de la rémunération des heures de nuit
mais aussi par des mesures structurelles
et c'est ça qui nous attend demain la
libération massive du temps médical je
l'ai dit former plus et mieux de
soignants dans la ligne de la
suppression du numérus clausus mieux
organiser l'hôpital en sortant de cette
logique financière concurrentielle entre
établissement en travaillant à l'échelle
des territoires dans un esprit de
coopération mieux valorisé également la
pénibilité du travail en particulier la
pénibilité de travail de lit
les urgences sur la dernière ligne de
défense de notre système de santé c'est
en agissant sur l'ensemble de ces
leviers en amont et en aval que nous
leur permettrons de gagner ce défi je
vous remercie
c'est le Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe Nayet pour le groupe
socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie monsieur le
ministre vous le savez l'article 73 de
la loi égalitée réelle en outre-mer voté
à l'unanimité en février 2017 à
instaurer l'expérimentation durant 5 ans
de la stratégie du bon achat ultramarin
dans le cas de la commande publique
locale l'objectif étant de favoriser par
l'achat publique l'émergence de nouveaux
opérateurs locaux le développement
économique et donc la création d'emplois
avec deux dispositions la première qui a
permis jusqu'en février dernier aux
acheteurs publics de réserver jusqu'à un
tiers de leur marché aux petites et au
moyen de entreprises locales la seconde
concernant les marchés supérieurs à
500.000 euros et l'obligation de
présenter un plan de sous-traitance
prévoyant le montant des modalités de
participation des PME locales ce
dispositif s'éteintra à la fin du mois
de mars vous le savez également dans nos
territoires la commande publique influe
fortement sur l'activité économique
dispositif de différenciation sont des
leviers primordiaux pour le
développement de notre tissu économique
composé à 93% de très petites
entreprises et dans les deux tiers n'ont
pas de salariés et ne répondent pas
d'elle-même aux appels d'offres cette
stratégie du bon achat est typiquement
une des réponses adaptées aux
problématiques économiques et sociales
de nos territoires en permettant plus de
concurrence donc d'engendrer une baisse
des prix et développer l'emploi local et
ainsi réduire la pauvreté qui frappe de
trop nombreuses familles bref
l'obligation de sous-traitance des PME
locale en ce qu'elle facilite leurs
accès leur accès et leur développement
au sein de plus gros marché dans une
enquête publiée par le Haut Conseil de
la commande publique de la Réunion il
est proposé de reconduire ces
dispositions plusieurs recommandations
ont été émises pour faire évoluer et
rendre plus efficient ces dispositifs
dans cette enquête 78% des acheteurs
interrogés demande une reconduction
améliorée des dispositifs vous l'avez
compris ma question est simple monsieur
le ministre comment comptez-vous
ces dispositifs et les améliorer merci
le député
la question vous avez raison les marchés
publics qui représentent environ pour
l'ensemble du territoire national 120
milliards d'euros par an sont un
puissant levier d'orientation de
l'économie et sur ces 120 milliards
environ 58%. donc pas loin de 60 %
étaient des PME pour ce qui est des
titulaires du marché public représentant
30% du montant global de ces derniers et
donc la question que vous posez et que
vous avez posé puisque je pense que à
l'époque vous étiez déjà député en
février 2017 quand la loi laquelle vous
faites référence a été votée et tout à
fait pertinente notamment dans les
départements que vous représentez vous
l'avez dit le dispositif expérimental
qui s'atteindra dans quelques semaines
visaient la possibilité pour les
acheteurs de réserver un tiers de leur
marché public au PME local une
obligation présentée un plan de
sous-traitance locale pour les marchés
supérieurs à 500 000 euros
force cette constater malheureusement
que ce dispositif a été loin d'avoir du
succès puisque seuls 4% des acheteurs
seulement l'ont mise en oeuvre notamment
à cause d'un risque juridique lié à
l'incision du texte voté à l'époque et
un manque de clarification sur les
secteurs économiques concernés nous ne
voyons pas donc à ce stade un intérêt
réel a prorogé ce dispositif en l'état
dans les mêmes conditions au vu de sa
faible mobilisation sur la terrain Bruno
Le Maire a eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
récemment nous souhaitons porter en 2023
un projet de loi de réindustrialisation
verte dans le cadre duquel la commande
publique doit avoir toute sa part je
vous engage donc à participer au
consultations qui auront lieu dans le
cadre de la préparation de ce projet de
loi un certain nombre de parlementaires
dont Bruno Bruno millienne sur les bancs
de la majorité vont s'impliquer dans le
sujet de la commande publique je vous
engage à vous rapprocher d'eux pour
porter des sujets particuliers pour les
départements d'outre-mer dont vous avez
dit les particularités font que la
commande publique a sans doute
les conditions particulières qu'on doit
intégrer dans des dispositions
législatives mais pour autant en
assurant l'égalité de tous et toutes
devant les territoires et le respect
vous le savez du droit européen en
attendant vous le savez dans le mandat
précédent nous avons voté des
dispositions qui visent à intégrer
davantage des enjeux environnementaux et
sociétaux je vous engage à vous en
saisir merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Marie Fiévet pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci de la présidente ma question
s'adresse d'État chargée des anciens
combattants et de la mémoire ce mercredi
4 janvier le film tirailleur réalisé par
Mathieu vapier sortait au cinéma ce film
qui se déroule en 1917 raconte
l'histoire des jeunes tierneaux joués
par Alassane young recruté de force dans
un village sénégalais par l'armée
française et de son père Bakary incarné
par Omar Sy
la sortie du film relance l'intérêt mais
aussi certaines polémiques autour de la
mémoire et de l'histoire de ces unités
coloniales recrutées dans les différents
territoires de l'Empire français ne les
oublions pas l'histoire des tirailleurs
est souvent méconnue
créé en 1857 le statut Thierry arsenet
et donné aux hommes recrutées dans toute
la Flex subsaharienne faisant partie du
corps militaire des troupes coloniales à
la création du premier régiment ils
étaient environ 500 lors de la Grande
Guerre ces pilot 200 000 tirailleurs qui
se sont battus sous le drapeau français
les tirailleurs auront jusqu'au guerres
de décolisations et d'indépendance
service à mes françaises ils étaient
engagés dans les combats pendant un
deuxième guerre mondiale ou encore un
Indochine à Madagascar ou en Algérie où
ils intervenaient comme des forces de
l'Empire français
les régiments anti ailleurs seront
définitivement dissous en 1962 en
réponse à cet engagement et malgré des
polémiques pouvant resurgir l'État se
doit d'apporter et apporte une
reconnaissance juste à ses anciens
combattants
ainsi madame la secrétaire d'État
au-delà de l'actualité cinématographique
pourriez-vous d'une part nous rappeler
qu'elle a été la réalité historique de
l'apport du tirailleurs à l'armée
française durant les nombreuses
décennies et au cours desquelles ils ont
été employés combien sont-ils
aujourd'hui et qu'elle est leur
situation géographique et sociales les
autres parts pouvez-vous nous préciser
comment l'État et le gouvernement
accompagne ses anciens grands
combattants et le rapport ainsi la
reconnaissance qu'il aurait dû je vous
remercie je vous remercie c'est la
parole est à Madame Patricia mirales
secrétaire d'État chargé des anciens
combattants et de la mémoire merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
Fiévé les tirailleurs sénégalais sont
des combattants issus des anciens
colonies d'Afrique succès à riennes qui
se sont engagés au sein de l'armée
française pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale près de 200 000 d'entre eux se
sont engagés pour des femmes notre
drapeau
leur contribution pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale vaut à deux d'entre eux
de reposer dans la crypte du Mont
Valérien il se sont battus vaillamment
avec honneur et fierté pour notre pays
ils sont l'objet d'une attention
constante de mon secrétariat d'État sous
l'autorité de Sébastien Lecornu ministre
des Armées
les marques de reconnaissance ne
manquent pas mais la reconnaissance est
un travail continu depuis mon dernier
depuis mon entrée au gouvernement j'ai
travaillé avec lonac VG pour pouvoir
dénombrer précisément aujourd'hui une
trentaine de tirailleurs sénégalais
octogénaires et nosogénaire vivent dans
des foyers de travailleurs plutôt à
Bondy essentiellement à Bondy
avec Jean-Christophe combe ministre des
Solidarités et marque PHENO ministre de
l'Agriculture nous avons levé à titre
exceptionnel l'obligation de résider en
France pour la perception du minimum
vieillesse Alpha qui puisse finir leur
jour dans leur pays c'était une question
d'humanité en décembre après les avoir
rencontrés à Bondy ils montent
accompagné pour le ravivage de la Flamme
sous l'Arc de Triomphe c'était un grand
moment la vérité du film avec
Omar Sy et de rappeler aux Français une
page de notre histoire au sein de mon
secrétariat d'État qui est celui de la
reconnaissance de la réparation et de la
mémoire je m'assure que la nation
considère ces Grands Anciens Combattants
avec respect et attention vous pouvez
compter sur moi monsieur le député
Fiévez sur ma détermination pour
continuer à accompagner ces grands
tirailleurs sénégalais merci je vous
remercie madame la ministre la parole
Giovanni Williams pour le groupe GDR
allez-y mon cher collègue
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres
vous le savez
la justice a rendu une ordonnance de
non-lieu dans l'affaire ou plutôt du
scandale de l'empoisonnement au
chlordécone
cette décision n'est évidemment pas
comprise par la population qui a été
empoisonnée à cause d'une décision
gouvernementale autorisant la
prorogation de l'utilisation de cette
molécule de la mort
vous êtes le premier maillon dans cette
chaîne de responsabilité
c'est donc de nous dire que 92 millions
sur 700 suffisent et suffiront à pallier
vos responsabilités cessez donc de
couvrir vos erreurs par des plans qui ne
feront catiser l'incompréhension du
peuple en souffrance déjà
il ne s'agit pas d'attendre une décision
judiciaire chez un collègue mesdames
messieurs
il s'agit pour vous
d'être au rendez-vous de l'histoire
madame la Première ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres
quand allez-vous prendre la mesure de
vos responsabilités quand allez-vous
indemniser toute la population touché
dans sa chair et dans son âme par cet
empoisonnement par cette non
reconnaissance qui nous tue aussi un peu
plus chaque jour merci
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
karenco ministre en charge des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
William je constate comme vous la
décision prise par les autorités
judiciaires en toute indépendance
la pollution au chlore déconne est un
sujet très grave qui suscite l'angoisse
et parfois de la colère
venez de le dire je le sais c'est nos
concitoyens antillais
en tant que ministre en charge de
l'outre-mer avec Gérald Darmanin et
l'ensemble du gouvernement notre
priorité est de protéger leur santé des
secteurs économiques impactés dans
phoque et de renforcer les recherches
pour améliorer l'ensemble des terrains
nous devons continuer à avancer dans le
chemin ouvert pour la première fois par
le Président de la République en 2018
qui est le premier à avoir reconnu la
responsabilité de l'État
sous son impulsion des avancées fortes
ont déjà été obtenus reconnaissance du
cancer de la BAC prostate comme maladie
professionnelle ouvrant droit
indemnisation
analyse gratuite de taux de chords dans
le sang pour toute la population ainsi
que des sols pour les agriculteurs et
les particuliers grâce aux travaux de
recherche capacité de réduire par deux
la teneurs de chlore des cônes dans le
sens six mois en consommant des produits
non contaminés accompagnement des
agriculteurs et des particuliers pour
cultiver des produits sains y compris
sur des terres contaminées
par ailleurs un effort national de la
recherche est engagé avec cinq projets
sur la dépollution des sols un sur
l'impact de la chlordécone sur la
fertilité féminine ce sont ainsi une
quarantaine de laboratoires de recherche
dans l'Hexagone et dans les outre-mer
qui sont mobilisés le colloque
scientifique il rencontre terrain du
mois de décembre dernier ont été
l'occasion de porter à la connaissance à
la connaissance les nombreuses avancées
ils ont aussi montré qu'il restait
beaucoup pas faire et nous devons le
faire je me rendrai en Martinique dans
les jours qui viennent c'est à dire à
compter de jeudi j'aurai l'occasion d'en
parler avec l'ensemble des acteurs
locaux
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur Williams
monsieur le ministre
Desmond tout ou disait il n'y a pas de
paix sans justice il n'y a pas de paix
sans responsabilité merci je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Balard
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci Madame
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Agnès peniere une
ministre de la transition énergétique
parlons du marché régulier l'énergie ou
l'art de créer un problème là où il ne
devrait pas y en avoir depuis 6 mois le
gouvernement raconte des fariboles et
des carabistouilles aux Français vous
affirmez que nous nous voulons sortir du
marché européen de l'énergie mais
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire couper les
câbles les interconnexions les réseaux
non nous avons toujours réclamé le juste
prix c'est-à-dire revenir sur la règle
européenne de fixation du prix c'est
complètement différent retrouvez des
tarifs réglementés mais pas vrai ceux
qui tenaient compte il y a encore
quelques années du coût réel de la
production grâce à cela vous auriez
d'ailleurs fait économiser à la France
des milliards d'euros et éviter que
notre dette explose nous on l'as
spéculation mais oui à la souveraineté
cela éviterait par exemple à Emmanuel
Macron de déclarer je cite qu'il en
avait assez de ceux qui faisait des
profits excessifs alors vous voyez c'est
très bien de pleurer sur le der renversé
mais le mieux c'est pas renverser la
casserole face à l'évidence vous nous
dites à présent que vous faites tout
pour réformer ce mécanisme moi qu'on
puisse dire c'est que c'est pas du
rapide le patron du BDF monsieur route
des yeux appelé il y a quelques jours
Emmanuel Macron à je cite engagé un bras
de fer avec l'Allemagne sur ce sujet
craignant au passage une nouvelle vague
de désindustrialisation de la France si
ce mécanisme européen n'était pas
réformé ce qu'il y a c'est que pour
engager un bras de fer et bien il faut
de la volonté et du courage politique
mes questions est-ce que vous en avez
par ailleurs en juillet 2023 c'est à
dire dans six mois maintenant il n'y
aura plus de tarifs réglementés pour le
gaz alors ma question est double que
comptez-vous faire pour éviter
l'asphyxie des ménages et des
entreprises pour les prix du gaz et
quand comptez-vous reprendre le contrôle
de la fixation du prix de l'électricité
je vous remercie
son énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Balard merci de me donner d'abord
l'occasion de rappeler la politique du
gouvernement une politique du
gouvernement qui est la plus protectrice
d'Europe pour les ménages français
puisque nous payons puisque vous payer
le prix de l'électricité le plus bas
d'Europe pour les très petites
entreprises puisqu'elles payent le prix
l'électricité le plus bas d'Europe et
pour les PME puisqu'elles même
bénéficient de la protection au travers
de l'amortisseur et des aides du guichet
de Bercy les plus généreuses d'Europe
pourquoi parce que nous serons toujours
aux côtés des Français et toujours aux
côtés des entreprises comme nous l'avons
été ces dernières années au bénéfice de
la croissance au bénéfice de l'emploi et
aux bénéfice de la souveraineté de notre
économie
vous m'interrogez sur la situation du
marché européen je vais vous rappeler
quelques données de base aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une situation nous
importons de l'électricité aujourd'hui
nous avons la capacité à produire plus
d'électricité sur le territoire français
et un groupe le vôtre refuse de voter un
projet de loi qui doit nous permettre de
développer plus de capacités de
production d'électricité alors pardon
monsieur le député Balard soyez
cohérents et soutenez la souveraineté
énergétique de notre pays
merci beaucoup madame la ministre vous
n'avez plus le temps mon cher collègue
donc la parole est à Madame Marie pochon
pour le groupe écologiste merci madame
la Présidente
2,3 millions de personnes mobilisées une
condamnation historique en 2021 qui
exhortait l'État français à prendre
toute mesure utile pour le climat avant
le 31 décembre 2022 madame la Première
ministre cela vous rappelle peut-être
quelque chose oui c'était l'affaire du
siècle ce siècle débutant encore et
devrait se terminer désormais à plus 4
degrés et cette affaire n'a jamais aussi
bien porté son nom la France a réduit de
seulement 0,3% ces émissions de gaz à
effet de serre sur le premier semestre
2022 elle est devenue faute d'une vision
claire de notre autonomie énergétique
cocorico le plus grand importateur de
gaz de schiste américain tandis que
cette année est définitivement la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée
sécheresse incendie perte agricole
absence de neige auront eu au moins un
point positif la prise de conscience
pendant ces vœux de notre président de
la République qui semblait découvrir les
impacts des changements climatiques qui
auraient pu prédire qui aurait pu
prédire à l'évidence madame la Première
ministre les 99% des scientifiques du
monde les 27 Coop le GIEC depuis 1988
les associations et experts qui alertent
pour que nous vous représentants
politiques puissiez agir avec toutes les
cartes en main
qui aurait pu prédire ces mots sont la
preuve d'un déni de responsabilité de
politique hors-sol face à la crise
climatique et l'effondrement de la
biodiversité qui concerne plus que tout
autre sujet que nous discuterons dans
cette assemblée tout simplement notre
capacité dans quelques dizaines d'années
à vivre sur cette terre
nous vivons dans le monde de demain avec
la société d'hier deux condamnations
pour une action climatique 0 objectif
concret dans le texte d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables et pourtant ce
sont celles et ceux qui se font la voix
de l'urgence d'agir qui sont accusés
surveillés condamnés vous en faites des
criminels des éco-terroristes mais les
criminels ne sont-ils pas plutôt ceux
qui regardent le monde s'enflammer en
restant les bras croisés madame la
Première ministre votre gouvernement
Bafou les lois de la République en
refusant d'exécuter ses obligations
légales merci beaucoup comment osez vous
menacer celles et ceux qui vous
demandent de respecter la loi et les
décisions de justice je vous remercie
tous la parole est à Madame Espagne et
renacher ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
pochon
la condamnation du gouvernement français
pour une action climatique entre 2015 et
2018 un gouvernement auquel votre groupe
politique participait et dans lequel il
avait un rôle instrumental sur ce sujet
là sous la responsabilité du président
Hollande vous m'interrogez sur ce que
les gouvernements de président Macron
ont fait pour rattraper le temps perdu
et corriger votre inaction climatique et
je vais vous répondre dès 2008 le rythme
de réduction des gaz à effet de serre a
été multipliée par deux par rapport à
votre bilan depuis 2018 la France a voté
un agenda de réforme ambitieuse en
matière écologique accélération de la
décarbonation de l'industrie in économie
de 5 millions de tonnes de gaz à effet
de serre par an interdiction la location
des passoires thermiques plan pour
développer les mobilités vertes petite
ligne de train vélo covoiturage
plus fort sans précédent de rénovation
thermique des bâtiments publics et de
logements plan sobriété ou plus
récemment un plan d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables dont vous avez
annoncé que vous ne voterez pas le volet
législatif je ne reviendrai pas enfin
sur l'action décisive de la France pour
faire adopter le paquet climat au niveau
européen alors madame la députée pochon
en matière d'action climatique il y a
ceux qui parlent et ceux qui agissent
vous avez encore la possibilité d'être
dans cette deuxième catégorie en votant
le projet de loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Madame Nathalie serres pour
le couple les républicains
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer monsieur le ministre mardi 3
janvier dernier à Écully commune de ma
circonscription située sur la métropole
lyonnaise un homme a été tué au pied
d'une bâtiment abritant un centre social
une crèche et une école à l'heure de la
sortie des écoles
sur fond de trafic de drogue ce drame
n'est malheureusement pas le premier il
sera certainement pas le dernier dans
tous l'Hexagone ces situations se
multiplient que ce soit à Marseille à
Nantes à Lyon ou même à Mayotte la
violence est quotidienne la politique de
la ville menée depuis 2014 laisse ses
quartiers gangrenés par toutes sortes de
trafic à l'abandon et sans perspective
la déclassification des zones urbaines
sensibles en simple quartier politique
de la ville en 2015 a eu pour seul effet
de sortir plus de 800 quartiers
difficiles des radars on a simplement
caché la poussière sous le tapis
aujourd'hui les services de secours les
médecins et même les forces de l'ordre
sont reçus à coup de tir de mortiers ou
de jettes parpaing les habitants de ces
quartiers ont besoin de vous en 2021 le
nombre de victimes par homicide était en
hausse tout comme celui des victimes des
coûts et blessures volontaires quant
allez vous prendre la mesure de
l'exaspération des français quand l'État
va-t-il décider de conquérir ces
territoires abandonnés quand allez-vous
donner aux forces de l'ordre les moyens
légaux et matériels de combattre les
trafiquants je vous remercie de votre
réponse
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame la députée je
peux partager un certain nombre de
constats notamment le fait que la loi de
2014 n'était pas une bonne loi vous avez
parfaitement raison j'ai revêté contre
lorsque j'étais dans cette hémicycle
puisque la politique de la ville mis en
place alors par ce gouvernement a fait
par carriage de 100 mètres par 200
mètres sortir des radars de la politique
de la vie vous avez raison un certain
nombre de quartiers dit difficile qu'il
soit fait des quartiers populaires qui
ont besoin de davantage de République en
revanche comme je peux être moins
d'accord avec vous c'est lorsque vous
comparez les chiffres en ne citant
d'ailleurs sans doute de façon exprès
j'imagine que l'année 2021 puisque en
2022 madame la députée vous auriez dû
noter que la délinquance BC est
singulièrement au deuxième semestre 2022
si je prends l'exemple de ces trois
derniers mois que nous avons vécu
puisque vous multipliez les exemples il
s'agit de moins 15% de vol avec violence
il y a 18 homicides en moins dans le
trim par rapport à aide avant et il y a
effectivement moins 30% de points de
deal sur le territoire national avec
plus de 200% parfois d'opérations
antidrogue c'est 2000 opérations
antidrogues par mois qui sont menées
dans notre territoire a commencé par le
vôtre madame la députée puisque dans le
Rhône c'est moins 50 % de violence dans
les transports et moins 30% de vol de
violence et d'atte aux personnes nous
devons continuer ce travail et c'est en
augmentant les effectifs de la police et
de la gendarmerie que nous y arrivons
dans le Rhône par exemple madame la
députée c'est trois fois plus de
policiers et de gendarmes dans la
métropole lyonnaise qui nous permet de
tenir ses objectifs oui les policiers
gendarmes font un travail important
Paris millions ne s'est pas fait en un
jour nous continuons merci de votre
soutien je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame serre oui monsieur le
ministre merci pour votre réponse mais
dans les transports c'est accessoirement
le c'est accessoirement la région et
Monsieur Wauquiez qui palier aux
difficultés de et au manque de policiers
dans dans
de transport il faut quand même la
violence et l'ultra violence se
banalisent les habitants et ont besoin
de sécurité les mères ont besoin de
l'engagement et du soutien de l'État
monsieur le ministre c'est tout
simplement ce qu'on attend d'un état de
droit c'est tout ce qu'on demande
féminisme merci Madame mais monsieur
Wauquiez n'a rien à voir dans l'affaire
les policiers c'est l'état français qui
l'aimait dans les métros dans les bus
dans les lignes de tram vous pourriez
remercier l'état madame et vous savez
vous savez madame vous ne combattez pas
le Front national malheureusement en
faisant en faisant un tableau noir de la
situation
vous permettrez aux policiers et aux
gendarmes de faire un travail admirable
en remarquant leur bons résultats et
nier les bons résultats d'aujourd'hui
madame saigner le travail des policiers
des gendarmes c'est pas je crois du
niveau de leur présentation nationale
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
ce Luc Lamirault pour le groupe horizon
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Économie
monsieur le ministre vous le savez je
défends depuis plusieurs mois avec le
groupe horizon et à parenté le principe
d'une résiliation à tout moment et sans
frais des contrats de fourniture de gaz
d'électricité pour les entreprises et
les collectivités territoriales
beaucoup ont effectivement été
contraintes de souscrire à l'automne des
contraintes sur la base de prix
exceptionnellement élevés qui les place
aujourd'hui dans une situation
et intenable avec le président de la
République Bruno Le Maire a annoncé la
semaine dernière des mesures fortes qui
vont dans le bon sens et que je tiens à
saluer d'abord avec la possibilité de
donner aux artisans boulangers de
résilier sans frais et à tout moment
leur contrats puis avec l'étendue du
bouclier tarifaire à 600 000 très
petites entreprises afin que leurs
factures n'excède pas un tarif de 280
euros le mégawatt en moyenne sur l'année
si les certains que ces mesures
d'urgence que nous appelions de nos vœux
sont bienvenus
envisagez-vous monsieur le ministre un
mécanisme plus pérenne pour qu'à
l'avenir les petites et moyens
d'entreprises ne soient plus captives
sur la durée de prix anormalement
excessif
quand le collectivité territoriale le
filet de sécurité défendu par le groupe
horizon permet un premier soutien pour
autant elle reste contrainte dans le
contexte actuel de fermer l'accès à des
équipements et services publics
essentiels et de leur réduire leurs
investissements aussi on va
envisagez-vous monsieur le ministre
détendre collectivités la portier la
portée des récentes annonces
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie
si madame la Présidente merci pour votre
question et surtout merci pour vos
alertes on a eu l'occasion tous des deux
dans le cadre d'un déplacement à Agen il
y a une dizaine de jours d'évoquer à
nouveau ce sujet et vous faites partie
des membres de la majorité qui nous ont
alerté très tôt sur le fait que les
dispositifs que nous avions d'ores et
déjà annoncé devaient sans doute faire
l'objet d'un élargissement et d'un
renforcement pour notamment les très
petites entreprises les boulangers et
autres qui du fait de la très forte
hausse des prix de l'énergie observés à
l'automne dernier à un moment où
certains d'entre eux devaient renégocier
les contrats c'était retrouvé dans des
contrats qui faisaient l'objet de hausse
pardon
extrêmement forte vous l'avez dit
à la fois alerté par certains d'entre
vous et sur l'impulsion du Président de
la République nous avons annoncé
vendredi des réponses extrêmement fortes
qui font qu'aucune des TPE de France
quel que soit le contrat dans lequel
elle est entrée pourra avoir un bouquet
tarifaire qui de fait plafonnera sont
tarif moyen de l'électricité à 280 euros
le Megawatt pour l'année 2023 et ce
c'était important sans passer par une
renégociation des contrats qui
risquaient du vent le nombre de TPE
concernés d'emboliser à la fois les TPE
eux même renégocier un contrat ça prend
du temps et les fournisseurs d'énergie
dont nous souhaitons qu'ils soient avant
tout au service de leurs clients et donc
cette révision des contrats généralisés
va permettre de baisser les factures de
manière extrêmement forte et de
retrouver des prix beaucoup plus viables
je le répète l'économie française
aujourd'hui résiste extrêmement bien au
choc énergétique auquel l'ensemble de
l'Europe fait face c'est à grande partie
grâce aux mesures annoncées adoptées par
le gouvernement c'est aussi en grande
partie liée à la résilience de notre
tissu industriel et commercial qui
résiste très bien
remercie long remercions les pardon tous
et toutes et continuons à suivre la
dispositif vous avez évoqué
éventuellement quelques dispositifs
adaptés voyons comme ça évolue mais pour
l'instant on a vraiment une économie
française qui résiste bien félicitons-en
nous et continuons à suivre le
dispositif merci merci
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Frédéric Mathieu pour le groupe
la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
le 23 décembre dernier un homme déjà
condamné pour des violences racistes a
ouvert le feu au centre culturel Kurt de
Paris faisant trois morts et plusieurs
blessés j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
assurer les familles de victimes de mon
entière solidarité
le 23 décembre donc la thèse vite
propagée était celle d'un racisme
pathologique
si combien de souligner que le racisme
n'est pas une maladie mais un délit qui
a conduit ici au crime d'assassinat la
similitude avec le triple assassinat du
9 janvier 2013 pose question le local de
la rue d'Enghien est certes publics mais
le jour et l'heure de l'attentat
correspondait initialement à un
rendez-vous qui devait réunir plusieurs
dizaines de représentantes Kurdes tout
comme en 2013 l'individu est isolé en
2013 les jours de l'assassin atteint une
tumeur au cerveau était comptée en 2022
l'assassin a été maîtrisée avant de
tenter de mettre fin à ses jours tout
comme en 2013 sont visés des personnes
impliquées dans la communauté kurde
comme nous savons désormais que
l'attentat de 2013 porte l'empreinte des
services secrets turcs l'identité du
mode opératoire doit vous inciter à
considérer très sérieusement la piste
d'une nouvelle ingérence de la Turquie
entendez-vous travailler cette hypothèse
qui pose autant une question de
souveraineté que la question de la
sécurité des ressortissants d'un peuple
ami qui paye déjà très cher sa simple
existence en Turquie
en ce cas
en ce cas entendez-vous réduire le
secret défense au strict minimum pour
que les familles des victimes ne soient
pas confrontées à la même absence de
réponse que celle de l'attentat de 2013
enfin avez-vous d'ores et déjà mis en
place des mesures pour garantir la
sécurité de l'ensemble des Kurdes de
France et de leur lieu de réunion je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente Madame et
Monsieur les députés monsieur le député
je veux également moi aussi comme je
l'ai fait le jour même
de ces horribles assassinats apportées
aux familles des victimes et au kurde en
particulier bien évidemment
nos plus sincères condoléances et notre
accompagnement monsieur préfet de police
monsieur le garde des Sceaux a pu
recevoir d'ailleurs les représentants à
plusieurs reprises de la communauté
kurde et notamment de ceux qui étaient
particulièrement touchés rue d'Enghien
je veux aussi remercier les personnes
qui ont arrêté cette personne qui était
rentrée dans le salon de coiffure et
étirant sur des personnes qui étaient là
et les forces de police qui sont
extrêmement rapidement arrivées et les
forces de secours qui ont pu je crois
limiter si tant que cela puisse être un
mot possible le bilan extrêmement
meurtrier de cette tuerie je veux aussi
vous dire Monsieur député que nous avons
pris bien sûr toutes les mesures de
protection de la communauté kurde de
encore lieu culturel mais aussi et après
une longue discussion bien sûr avec
l'ensemble des préfets des
manifestations qui en sont suivies pour
exprimer leurs colères ou faire montre
de leur condoléances je peux cependant
monsieur le député être surpris par vos
propos ce n'est pas dans un état de
droit au ministre d'un intérieur ou
gouvernement français que d'étudier des
pistes mais c'est au magistrat et les
magistrats agissent indépendamment de
toute action politique et ce sont les
magistrats qui se saisissent et qui
d'ailleurs qualifient eux-mêmes les
faits terroristes ou pas terroriste et
qui creuse ou non tel ou telle piste et
il me semble monsieur le député qu'en
posant la question comme vous la posez
soit vous ignorez totalement l'État de
droit et où vous pensez que le ministère
de l'Intérieur comment des enquêtes
judiciaires
soit monsieur le député malheureusement
vous utilisez ce drame
ignoble pour faire croire que l'État
français a des choses à cacher et ne
creusent pas cette piste je vous demande
monsieur le député dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale de respecter les
principes de l'État de droit et de
laisser les magistrats faire le travail
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Kep Pascal board
pour le rassemblement national
personne n'est en train
d'instrumentaliser ce drame et sachez
d'ailleurs et vous y êtes invité que le
12 j'organise avec le cdkf un colloque
le 12 janvier ici pour lever secret
défense concernant pour aboutir à la
vérité que la justice merci beaucoup
donc la parole est à vous madame board
pour le rassemblement national oui
vieillissante et que de fait les
personnes âgées sont de plus en plus
nombreuses à venir aux urgences nous ne
pouvons nous ne devons plus accepter la
maltraitance des patients la surcharge
des urgences étant et ceci est largement
prouvé responsables d'une augmentation
de la mort immortalité ces mots sont de
vous monsieur le ministre lorsque vous
étiez président d'un syndicat SAMU
urgence de France notre système de soins
est à bout de souffle vous en avez fait
le constat et il faut sans attendre
prendre des mesures afin de rétablir des
conditions de soins descente et
sécuritaires avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard et que ne se multiplient des
situations que nous redoutons tous à
savoir des décès faute d'avoir pu être
soigné à temps ou d'avoir pu être soigné
dans de bonnes conditions il en va de
notre de votre responsabilité en contenu
en tant que ministre il en va de la
responsabilité du gouvernement il en va
de notre responsabilité de parlementaire
il en va de l'honneur de la France je
souhaiterais donc savoir Monsieur le
Ministre si vous comptez prendre enfin
dans un avenir très proche des mesures
permettant de mettre un terme dès à
présent à cette maltraitance et des
patients et des soignants et ce sans
attendre une refondation du système
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre de
la santé et de la prévention
[Applaudissements]
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs
députés madame la députée borne je
remercie de votre diagnostic qui
malheureusement est connu et contre
lequel nous avons beaucoup d'actions à
faire vous auriez pu également
reconnaître les actions qui sont faites
depuis 6 mois quand même dans le cadre
de l'été que tout le monde nous a
annoncé cataclysmique et que nous avons
réussi à passer avec bien sûr l'appui
des professionnels de santé sur le
terrain alors je l'ai dit mon objectif
c'est bien sûr de prendre soin des
Françaises et des Français mais c'est
aussi de prendre soin des soignants qui
eux les sont auprès de nos concitoyens
tous les jours trois axes simplifiés
collaborer valoriser valoriser dans le
cadre de ces missions de santé publique
auprès des soignants alors plusieurs
solutions ont été en tout cas pistes ont
été dessinées par le Président de la
République le 6 janvier dernier du temps
de soins je n'y reviens pas travailler
sur l'organisation collective à
l'échelle humaine collective à l'échelle
des territoires c'est ce que nous avons
fait depuis quelques mois avec le
international de la refondation en santé
qui nous a permis d'identifier des
pistes spécifiques pour chaque
territoire l'organisation au sein de
l'hôpital à l'échelle des services là
aussi pour redonner du sens et puis
l'organisation au plus près des
individus sur le suivi de leur carrière
ça a été dit leur qualité de vie et ce
pacte que je souhaite passer avec les
élus des territoires pour améliorer la
qualité de vie des soignants en ce qui
concerne les transports les logements et
toutes les aides qu'on peut leur
apporter c'est ce qui était d'ailleurs
dans le PLFSS sur ce principe de guichet
unique troisième point la permanence est
l'universalité des soins en
reconnaissant les besoins en
reconnaissant la pénibilité en faisant
enfin tomber les barrières tomber les
barrières entre la ville et l'hôpital
entre les hôpitaux et les cliniques
entre les différents professionnels de
santé c'est ce que nous avons fait
pendant le covid et qui nous a permis de
passer cette crise covid il faut le
retrouver enfin reconnaître nous n'avons
pas beaucoup parlé le rôle du médecin
traitant généraliste les aides par le
guichet unique cette responsabilité
territoriale pour la permanence des
soins le dépl et continuer le
déploiement du service d'accès aux soins
travailler sur des rendez-vous non
honorés nos concitoyens qui n'ont pas de
médecins traitant je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
indépendant outre-mer et territoires
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre la
santé les urgences encore oui cette
année encore la période des fêtes de fin
d'année a été marquée par de grandes
difficultés pour les services des
urgences sur tout le territoire national
ce n'est pas nouveau début juin ça a été
dit le syndicat s'amuse urgence de
France alerté sur la situation déjà
fortement dégradée 120 services
d'urgence hospitalière répartis sur une
soixantaine de départements sont
confrontés à d'importants
dysfonctionnements parmi eux figurent
les hôpitaux de monde département le
Shiva et le chèque les indicateurs en
Ariège sont parmi les plus mauvais par
exemple l'agglomération de Saint-Girons
passer de 21 médecins en 1980 à 6
médecins aujourd'hui se voit en plus
confronté à la fermeture partielle de
son service d'urgence environ 5 jours
par mois faute de médecins à l'échelle
du département en un an et à effectif
constant voire en baisse les services de
régulation ont connu une hausse de 20%
de leur activité 6% de hausse de passage
en urgence et le taux d'hospitalisation
de nos hôpitaux augmenter lui de 18%. en
cause à la fois le vieillissement de la
population et la désertification de la
médecine de ville c'est donc la double
peine pour la population ariégeoise un
accès fortement dégradé aux soins de
ville mais aussi désormais trop souvent
aux urgences qui constituaient pourtant
le dernier rempart face à ce qui
ressemble non plus à de la
désertification médicale mais bien à de
la misère médicale l'égalité d'accès aux
soins n'est absolument plus assurée
aujourd'hui en Ariège et dans beaucoup
d'autres territoires français se sont à
la fois les soignants parfois contraints
d'opérer des sélections pour réguler
l'entrée des patients et la population
qui manifeste leur plus vives inquiétude
face à l'extrême tension du service des
urgences et au burn-out du système
hospitalier après deux années de
pandémie l'heure n'est plus à la
réflexion monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous me dire comment votre
gouvernement peut intervenir sans
attendre concrètement pour garantir aux
ariégeois aux Français confrontés aux
mêmes difficultés l'accès à un service
d'urgence digne d'un pays développé je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
François Braun ministre de la santé et
de la prévention
des députés monsieur le député panifu je
vous remercie d'avoir souligné ce
principe de difficulté au cours de cette
fin d'année fin d'année avec bien sûr
des absences des médecins mais aussi fin
d'année avec cette triple épidémie
j'aurais tendance à y revenir sur les
gestes barrières et la vaccination mais
je sais que vous avez largement entendu
le message alors cette difficulté des
services d'urgence vous la vous la
chiffrez de quelques années elle est
beaucoup plus ancienne malheureusement
et j'en sais directement quelque chose
et elle est liée à une difficulté au
niveau de la médecine de ville et il y a
aussi un dysfonctionnement au sein de
l'hôpital elle est surtout liée avec une
diminution globale de l'offre et une
augmentation des besoins par le
vieillissement de la population et par
les améliorations de la médecine au
palier d'indicateurs je serai bien sûr
ravi de discuter avec vous de cette
problématique ariégeoise que je connais
un petit peu pour bien connaître des
collègues qui sont là-bas mais je veux
aussi surtout revenir sur cette notion
de de besoin de soins plus que cette
notion d'offre je pense que certes il y
a des densité différentes mais c'est
surtout sur les besoins à la façon dont
nous allons reconstruire la réponse à
ses besoins vous avez parlé de la
régulation médicale oui la régulation
médicale est une des solutions le
président de la République l'a annoncé
nous allons
généraliser l'ensemble des services
d'accès aux soins en y mettant des
moyens des moyens humains des moyens
matériels parce que cette régulation
médicale est le meilleur moyen
d'orienter pertinemment les patients
dans le parcours de soins les
régulations médicales du service d'accès
aux soins savent où sont les réponses
savent quelle professionnelle ils
peuvent mobiliser nous allons là aussi
continuer ce qui a été mis en place cet
été à savoir valoriser les
professionnels de santé qui acceptent de
prendre en charge des patients dans le
cadre des soins non programmés tout ça
pour diminuer la pression en amont des
services d'urgence également au niveau
de Laval la réorganisation de l'hôpital
dont je parlais tout à l'heure autour
des services va permettre là aussi de
plus mobiliser sur la réponse aux soins
non programmés pas seulement au niveau
d'un établissement mais au niveau d'un
territoire en embarquant si je peux
m'écrire ainsi d'ensemble des
professionnels et des établissements du
territoire donc vous le voyez
nous sommes dans une logique d'action le
diagnostic est connu maintenant nous
appliquons le traitement
ma question la dernière s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur le ministre une
étude du service statistique de votre
ministère indique environ 21% des élèves
âgés de 15 ans n'ont pas un niveau
suffisant de compétence en compréhension
les cris culture mathématiques et
culture scientifique c'est un peu mieux
que la moyenne européenne avec des
chiffres allant de 22,3 à 22,9% pour ces
mêmes compétences mais cela reste malgré
tout inquiétant pour rappel sur une même
dictée de 67 mots sans complexité
extrême à la pivot proposé à quatre
générations depuis 1987 on est passé de
10,7 fautes à
19,4 en 2021
27% des examinés ont même commis plus de
25 erreurs
comme professeur de français je peux
vous le dire en toute franchise on nous
demande à présent en collège sans doute
pour notre survie de ne plus corriger
l'ensemble d'une copie de rédaction
c'est pour dire à cela s'ajoute une
perte de vocabulaire le linguiste
Bentolila indiqué en 2015 que 10 % de la
population française ne maîtrise que 400
à 500 mots contre 5000 en moyenne pour
la majorité des Français pour les
mathématiques le classement pizza
indique des résultats légèrement
supérieurs à la moyenne mais nous
restons tristement le pays numéro un des
inégalités l'Angleterre de Tony Blair en
imposant une heure de lecture
quotidienne dans les années 90 où
l'Allemagne avec une réforme profonde de
son système on réagit
en France en revanche on constate que la
collégienne que j'étais dans les années
90 sous le ministère de François Bayrou
bénéficiait de plus d'heures de français
en 40 ans en primaire et collège un
élève a perdu 522 heures de français je
tiens comme président du groupe livre a
rappelé le rôle que nous avons tous à
promouvoir la lecture et la vigilance
que nous devons avoir pour que soit
préserver des grignotages les heures
dédiées aux apprentissages fondamentaux
pouvez-vous revenir monsieur le ministre
sur les mesures annoncées pour répondre
à ce difficile constat et compléter
votre réponse précédente merci beaucoup
ma chère collègue la parole est à
Monsieur papenda ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame les députés
banniers je partage évidemment le
constat sévère mais il faut regarder la
vérité en face à propos des savoirs
fondamentaux ces dernières années un
travail important a été mené pour les
premières années de l'école primaire du
côté du cycle 2 en particulier des
travaux qui ont donné des résultats
intéressants on le voit en particulier
en éducation prioritaire nous devons
mettre désormais l'accent sur le cycle 3
c'est-à-dire le cours moyen et la
sixième vu dans un ensemble or comme je
l'indiquais précédemment un rapport du
de l'Inspection Générale a mis le doigt
sur un certain nombre de difficultés
dans les apprentissages en français et
en mathématiques je ne résumerai je ne
prendrai qu'un exemple c'est le la
question de la rédaction la question de
l'écriture qui n'occupe que 7% du temps
CM2 ce qui est évidemment insuffisant
nous devons donc mettre l'accent sur la
formalisation des apprentissages la
diversité et la régularité des
productions écrites et en mathématiques
la résolution des problèmes et le calcul
mental en 6e comme je l'ai indiqué si
une année charnière parce que c'est le
lieu de la grande divergence
c'est-à-dire le moment où les
trajectoires des élèves divergent entre
les élèves qui poursuivent une
trajectoire normale et puis ceux qui
vont plonger un quart des élèves en 6e
que l'on retrouve en troisième c'est
pourquoi nous devons mettre l'accent en
sixième sur un travail extrêmement
précis sur les fragilités que nous
allons
identifier que nous identifions grâce
aux évaluations de sixième de manière à
pouvoir travailler soit sur
l'orthographe soit sur la grammaire soit
sur les quatre opérations et résoudre et
travailler sur ces fragilités sur
l'ensemble de l'année de sixième
d'autres mesures en cinquième en
quatrième et en troisième pour faire du
collège un lieu qui ne soit plus le lieu
de l'échec d'une partie de nos
collégiens et qu'ils puissent poursuivre
du côté du lycée général et
technologique ou bien du lycée
professionnel merci beaucoup
vous propose de reprendre à 17h15 pour
le vote solennelle sur le projet de
Loire relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable